Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 119. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich freue mich, dass ihr wieder alle zu mir gefunden habt, hier bei Chaosradio Express, wo es ja eine ganze Reihe von technischen Sendungen gab, Schlag auf Schlag, bis das dann bei der letzten Sendung mal wieder ein bisschen umgeschlagen ist. Und heute marschiere ich weiter in eine andere Richtung und wollte mal ein Thema aufbringen, was schon ganz, ganz lange auf meiner Wunschliste ganz oben stand, etwas, womit ihr euch alle wahrscheinlich schon häufiger beschäftigt habt und manche auch die Finger nicht davon lassen können. Die Rede ist schlicht von Kaffee, das Getränk, was wir alle trinken, aber über das wir wahrscheinlich relativ wenig wissen. Und um das zu hinterfragen und zu erforschen, freue ich mich begrüßen zu können bei Chaosradio Express. Du bist Kaffee, würde ich mal sagen.
Von oben bis unten.
Du bist Kaffee. Du beschäftigst dich auf jeden Fall ausführlich mit Kaffee und vor allem hast du so einen kleinen Kaffeeladen hier in Berlin zusammen mit deinem Partner-Kompanion, der heißt?
Bonanza Coffee Heroes.
Bonanza Coffee Heroes, und da gibt es ganz leckeren Kaffee. Ich hatte das auch schon mal testen dürfen. Vor allem hat mich, was mich hier sehr überzeugt hat an dem Laden ist, wie konsequent der Laden ist. Man hat wirklich den Eindruck, es geht einfach primär im Wesentlichen um Kaffee. Also es handelt sich hier nicht so um so ein Kaffee mit Küche und Pipapo und so, sondern eigentlich gibt es nur Kaffee, oder?
Es gibt auch nur Kaffee, ja. Also wenn du unsere Menükarte hier anguckst, es gibt keine Bionate, es gibt kein Wasser. Tee haben wir, wenn jemand danach fragt, aber es ist wirklich nur Kaffee.
Hört das Wasser nicht auch zum Kaffee?
Ja, die Leute versuchen immer noch verzweifelt, Mineralwasser bei uns zu kaufen, dann sagen wir mal, da gibt es umsonst Leitungswasser gefiltert, das bitte hier.
Was ja in Berlin auch gute Qualität hat. Und das muss reichen, denn es geht sozusagen um den Kaffee und um nichts anderes. Ja, jetzt hast du dich schon sehr mit Kaffee auch beschäftigt. Also du machst nicht nur Kaffee, sondern du lebst auch Kaffee. Und ich habe so ein paar Fragen, die wollte ich doch mal anbringen. Und zwar vor allem, wie eigentlich dieses Getränk den Weg in unsere Gesellschaft geschafft hat. Also es gab ja auch mal eine Zeit ohne Kaffee. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange ist das jetzt schon her. Wann gab es denn immer keinen Kaffee?
Also vor dem 16. Jahrhundert.
Vor dem 16. Jahrhundert gab es keinen Kaffee?
Gab es keinen Kaffee in Europa, nein.
Oha. Und was haben die armen Menschen damals?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, stimmt. Bier gab es schon immer. Also keine Ahnung, seit wann es Bier gibt. Aber es geht hier nicht ums Bier.
Ja, wie es angefangen hat. Also die Äthiopier, sagt man, das waren die ersten, die Kaffee entdeckt haben. Dort wächst ja auch Wild. Die haben auch, da gibt es diese Legende von Kaldi, den Schafhürden, der dann sieht, wie die Schafe an einem Strauch rote Früchte essen und danach tanzen die Schafe wie wild herum. Oder Ziegen, vielleicht waren es auch Ziegen. Das sieht dann der Schaf der Ziegenhürde und probiert dann auch diese Beeren und merkt dann natürlich die Wirkung und das ist ganz toll und erzählt den Mönchen davon, die dort in der Nähe ein Kloster haben und so verbreitet sich dann halt der Kaffee. Eigentlich, um den Leuten zu helfen beim Beten, also da nicht einzuschlafen. Noch ein Tesschen Kaffee getrunken und über Äthiopien kamen dann halt die Araber nach Äthiopien über den Port Mokka und dort fingen dann die Äthiopier an mit den Arabern über den Port, über den Hafen Mokka, Kaffee zu handeln.
Deswegen heißt der Mokka Mokka? Okay, Mokka, also nicht Mekka, sondern Mokka auf äthiopischer Seite.
Ja, das war damals ein wichtiger Hafen. Und die Araber waren noch die ersten, die also die Pflanze mit ins Gepäck genommen haben und dann in Arabien halt kommerziell angebaut haben. Und die hatten ganz lange ein Monopol auf Kaffee, also in Jemen.
Aber man hat sich denn zu dem Zeitpunkt dann in Äthiopien schon so eine Kaffee-Kultur dann schon irgendwie entwickelt, bevor die Araber wenn ja nicht vorbeigekommen seien, weil sie zufällig gehört haben, dass irgendeiner sich am Strauch berauschte. Sondern das muss ja dann auch schon so.
Tatsächlich haben die, ähnlich wie die Japaner eine Tee-Zeremonie haben, haben die Äthiopier eine Kaffee-Zeremonie. Und da wird der halt frisch geröstet, gemahlen, aufgebrüht. Die dauert auch eine Weile, diese Kaffee-Zeremonie. Und dann wird dann halt zusammen Kaffee getrunken.
Und das hat sich schon umgesprochen, sozusagen, bei den Arabern?
Ja.
Und deswegen sind sie alle hingefahren.
Um besser beten zu können, ne?
Besser beten mit Kaffee.
Alkohol war ja nicht erlaubt.
Stimmt. Aber ohne Rausch geht es halt auch nicht in Arabien, sozusagen. Das heißt, okay, wir reden jetzt um welche Zeit? Das ist so jetzt vor 1600 auf jeden Fall.
Also vor 1600, das ist eine genaue Zahl.
Ist das überhaupt so genau überliefert?
Nein, auch nicht.
Aber so in diesen dunklen Zeiten. Also zumindest in Europa waren sie sehr, sehr dunkel, einerseits weil sie sich da alle schlecht benommen haben und andererseits gab es keinen Kaffee. Okay, das heißt, man kann also eigentlich sagen, die Wiege der Menschheit liegt irgendwie in Äthiopien und die Wiege des Kaffees auch.
Genau.
Das ist einfach so der Ort, weil wenn man heute an Kaffee denkt, dann würde ich es nicht sagen, dass man als Erstes an Äthiopien denkt. Also ich tue das nicht. Ich denke so, keine Ahnung, was denke ich denn eigentlich? Südamerika, Mittelamerika, so diese Region, das ist irgendwie das, was man heute so mit Kaffee assoziiert.
Ja, das ist auch ganz interessant, weil nach Brasilien kam das über Europa. Also die Araber hatten dann halt so ein Monopol da drauf. Und dann fing ja die Zeit an, wo die fleißigen Europäer in andere Länder…
Was heißt Monopol? Aber die haben nicht selber Kaffee angebaut?
Die haben selber Kaffee angebaut, kommerziell für sich. Und haben das auch ganz streng gehütet als Geheimnis. Also es gab da ganz drakonische Strafen, wenn man da irgendwie Saatgut oder Pflanzen gestohlen hätte. Da gibt es einen Fall von Baba Budan, das ist ein Inder. Der hat wohl als Erster eine Kaffee-Pflanze geklaut, mit nach Indien gebracht. Und die Holländer haben auch einen Setzling gestohlen und dann halt als erstes nach Europa gebracht.
Und das haben die Araber nicht mitbekommen?
Das haben die dann später doch noch mitbekommen. Aber das hat sich eh schon alles aufgelockert, weil dann die Türken zum Beispiel, als die vor Wiens Toren waren, dort auch ihre Kaffeesäcke liegen lassen mussten.
Hm, davon habe ich gehört.
Und deswegen haben wir ja auch diese Wiener Kaffeehauskultur, das wirklich historisch belegt, dass die Türken dort ihren Kaffee liegen lassen haben. Und da war ein, ich glaube, da war sogar Pole, hat das erkannt, dass es Kaffee ist und hat mit diesem Beutegut sozusagen das erste Wiener Kaffeehaus eröffnet.
Das heißt, man wusste sozusagen, dass es Kaffee gibt, aber keiner hatte welchen. Es hatten dann irgendwie nur die Araber und die Türken. Und die haben das aber auch bei ihren Fellzügen sozusagen als Dopingmittel quasi mitgenommen. Und als sie dann irgendwie vom Prinz Eugen, dem edlen Ritter, in die Flucht geschlagen wurden, dann war es geschehen um das Geheimnis. Das heißt, alles startete in Äthiopien, dann kamen die Araber und die Araber haben es im Prinzip, also jetzt durch diesen Vorfall kamen das überhaupt erst nach Europa.
Genau, nach Österreich.
Nach Österreich, das heißt, Österreich ist quasi das Einfallstor für Kaffee in Europa. Und das verdanken wir den Türken, weil sie irgendwie in die Flucht geschlagen wurden sozusagen.
Und da war noch eben dieser Pole, der wusste was das war und damit halt das erste Yumi Caféhaus eröffnet hat.
Das war bestimmt dann auch was total Verrugtes, oder?
Also was immer war mit Kaffee auch in den anderen europäischen Städten, wo es dann nach und nach auch kam, war, dass sich sehr oft Intellektuelle und Studenten hingezogen geführt haben zu Kaffee. Und dass viele politische Debatten in Kaffeehäusern auch stattfanden. Deswegen war das auch oft nicht gern gesehen.
Weil, ach so, das wirkt aufrührerisch sozusagen.
Ja genau, die Leute kommen und sprechen, denken angeregter.
Oha, das ist ja gefährlich, das könnte ja den Status Quo hinterfragen. Verstehe, also bei Drogen wiederholt sich das selbe Spiel eigentlich immer wieder. Egal, worum es sich dabei handelt. Wenn die Leute auf einmal anfangen zu denken und auf kluge Ideen zu kommen, dann kann das nicht gut sein. Trotzdem, also den Kaffee hat es ja zumindest, also dann nicht, also ich meine, es hat sich ja dann durchaus auch durchgesetzt. Aber bevor wir vielleicht auf diesen kulturellen Aspekt noch ein bisschen weiter eingehen, wird mich natürlich jetzt schon auch nochmal interessieren, wie denn sozusagen man überhaupt aufs Getränk gekommen ist. Weil bisher, also am Anfang haben sie ja einfach nur die Beere genascht, die an diesem Strauch hängen. Da muss man ja auch irgendwie erstmal auf diesen Plan kommen, die so weiter zu verarbeiten, um daraus dieses Getränk zu machen. Also was muss man denn überhaupt? Also Kaffee ist ein Strauch.
Kaffee ist ein Strauch, da sind die sogenannten Kaffeekirschen dran. Das sind immergrüne Pflanzen. Manche sind unreif, manche sind reif. Und nur die Reifen entwickeln halt diesen Rohkaffee, die grünen Bohnen, die, wenn man sie gut röstet hat, diese sehr komplexen aromatischen Komponenten entwickelt. Die Äthiopier haben auch schon selbst Kaffeegetränke gemacht. Also am Anfang haben sie wahrscheinlich das in Fett, nur in Fett, also die Kaffeebohnen zerrieben, roh und dann in Fett, also so wie so Kaffee-Müsli-Bars mitgenommen auf die Jagd. Auch wegen der Wirkung natürlich wieder.
So Müsli-Riegel-Style.
So Müsli-Riegel-Style als Kaffee, Energy-Kaffee-Bar.
Echt, das kommt ja auch gerade wieder. Das heißt, man nimmt einfach so die Bohnen und trocknet sie erst mal oder gar nicht mal.
Also damals in Äthiopien oder jetzt?
Naja, was weiß ich, wie das damals genau in Äthiopien war. Also ich meine, irgendwie muss man ja erst mal auf die Idee kommen, die zu rösten.
Also ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich zufällig.
So würde ich in die Pfanne gefallen. Okay, naja gut, das lässt sich natürlich heute schwer nachvollziehen, wie das nun kam. Aber sie sind halt irgendwie auf den Trichter gekommen. Aber sag mal mal, dieses Prinzip, Bohnen nehmen, Bohnen rösten.
Das kommt ursprünglich auch schon aus Äthiopien.
Und malen und dann irgendwie als Pulver sozusagen mit heißem Wasser Kaffee zu machen. Das hat sich schon komplett in Äthiopien entwickelt. Das war sozusagen.
Etwas gröber. Also ich habe mal so eine Zerromanie mitgemacht, das wird eher so zermahlen mit so einem Stößel. Und dann waren es aber die.
Du hast sie in Äthiopien mitgemacht?
Nein, in London. Und in Arabien haben die das wirklich mit der Kaffeemühle, mit der Mokka-Mühle und türkischen Kaffee einfach drüber gegossen. Der ist dann sehr fein gemahlen. Und das waren dann tatsächlich später dann die Italiener, die dann, aber das ist viel, viel später, die die Espressen-Maschinen entwickelt haben. Und dann natürlich Frau Melitta, die die Filtertüte erfunden hat.
Also die Österreicher waren aber die ersten, weil die Italiener machen ja ein ganz schön Aufhebens um ihren Kaffee und fühlen sich ja so ein bisschen als die Kaffeenation in Europa.
Ja, die Österreicher waren die ersten mit dem Kaffeehaus.
Das heißt, die Italiener haben eigentlich den Kaffee von den Österreichern bekommen. Geleitet von einem Polen. Also die Polen stecken hinter allem, aber die Österreicher waren so die ersten, die das dann sozusagen auch im Lande hatten. Und von dort ist es dann wahrscheinlich nach Italien gesägert, nehme ich mal an. So, aber dann haben sich da eigentlich vollkommen, vollkommen disjüngte oder zumindest, naja, weitgehend voneinander unbeeinflusste Kaffee-Kulturen entwickelt. Es gibt ja dann auch immer noch so verschiedene Methoden. Aber Deutschland war dann erstmal...
Deutschland kam ziemlich spät. Also da war, das in England noch viel aktiver, bevor die zu Tee über gewechselt haben, waren die eigentlich ziemlich stark im Kaffee-Konsum. Also zum Beispiel Lloyds Bank war eigentlich mal ein Kaffeehaus.
Die Lloyds Bank war ein Kaffeehaus.
Ja, hat als Kaffeehaus angefangen.
So als Café-Café, wo man sich hinsetzt und einen Kaffee bestellt.
Genau, wurde auch die One Penny University genannt, die Kaffeehäuser in London. Wurde dann aber abgelöst durch Tee. Ich glaube, wegen den Kolonien, die sie in Indien hatten. Also es ging ziemlich wild mit Kaffee. Also die ganze Geschichte des Kaffees ist ziemlich wild, hat auch viel mit Stehlen von Wissen zu tun. Also zum Beispiel sagt man das in Südamerika, im Gesamt-Südamerika, dass die fast 90% aller Kaffee-Pflanzen nur von einer Pflanze abschnammen. Und das ist eine Pflanze, die auch gestohlen worden ist, aus dem Gewächshaus vom französischen König.
Ach, das kann man genetisch nachweisen, oder wie?
Also da gibt es ganz wilde Geschichten, aber da muss man nicht wirklich reinlesen. Das führt vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu weit.
Ach, hier kann eigentlich gar nichts zu weit führen. Ich versuche gerade so ein bisschen diesen Scope zu machen. Also grundsätzlich irgendwie Äthiopien, die Araber haben sozusagen als erstes begriffen, was dahintersteckt und haben da sozusagen auch gleich ein bisschen Business gemacht. Dann kam es irgendwie über die Türken, kam es an diesen Polen, der hat irgendwie in Österreich die Kaffeehäuser gegründet. Dann ist es dann so langsam in das restliche Europa reingesickert und ab dann hat sich das eigentlich so als eigenständige Kaffeekultur verbreitet.
Kolonialismus ist ein ganz großes Thema natürlich. Also das hatte ich ja vorhin schon erzählt. Die Holländer hatten als erste auch einen Setzling geklaut und hatten das dann als erste Europäer kommerziell in Indonesien angebaut. Und die waren da auch ganz fleißig unter anderem.
War das dann nicht aber auch so, dass Kaffee, ich meine du hast ja schon gesagt, das war so ein bisschen auch unterdrückt worden, oder war zumindest erstmal nicht, weiß ich nicht, nicht stadthaft, nicht gern gesehen, oder wurde das auch so richtig verfolgt?
Also es gab so einige Fälle, dass dann religiöse Oberhäupter dagegen waren, aber die wurden immer, also Kaffee hat sich immer durchgesetzt. Sowohl in den islamischen Ländern, wo dann die Imanen sagen, ah das geht aber nicht, die Leute sind dann irgendwie zu angeregt. Wo dann die Oberhäupter sagen, nö, das ist doch super. Und also Kaffee konnte sich überall durchsetzen, auch wenn es da Gegenbewegungen gab.
Offensichtlich. Ja, wie sieht denn das heute eigentlich aus? Also heute, klar, Kaffee ist irgendwie überall, aber es gibt ja sicherlich auch Länder, wo mehr Kaffee-Konsum, also deutlich mehr Kaffee-Konsum stattfindet. Und, weiß nicht, gibt es auch Länder, die so den Kaffee komplett entsagen? Gibt es irgendwo irgendeinen Bereich dieser Welt?
Ich glaube Eskimos trinken keinen Kaffee.
Eskimos trinken keinen Kaffee.
Hab ich gehört.
Verdächtig.
Und, ja, wer trinkt keinen Kaffee? Die Koreaner trinken Kaffee, die Japaner sind auch ganz vorne an.
Eigentlich alle.
Eigentlich alle, außer die Eskimos.
Alle, außer den Eskimos, trinken Kaffee. So auch heute noch?
Ja, ja, doch, das stimmt.
Weil das nicht ihr Ding ist, verstehe. Aber wo kommt denn der Kaffee heute her? Also wenn man heute Kaffee kauft, ich habe ja schon gesagt, meine Wahrnehmung war, das kommt heute alles irgendwie aus Südamerika. Ist das irgendwie eine berechtigte Wahrnehmung oder stimmt das eigentlich gar nicht?
Also was im Brasilien vor allem ist, ist, dass es dort ein Massenanbau ist und auch schon also industrialisiert, der industrialisierte Anbau. Aber Kaffee wird in über 50 Ländern der Welt angebaut. Es kann sehr gut sein, dass dein Kaffee aus dem Supermarkt eben teilweise aus Afrika kommt oder aus Kolumbien, wahrscheinlich immer ein Brasilianer dabei ist. Aber es gibt also gerade auch bei anderen, es gibt auch Kaffee aus Indien, aus Vietnam, aus El Salvador, also Rwanda ist jetzt ziemlich im Korn, Malawi. Also Kaffee wird in unglaublich vielen Ländern angebaut.
Wechseln das auch eigentlich überall?
Das wächst nur um den Aquarius, wie heißt das, in einer bestimmten Breitengradzone, um den Äquator herum, in einer bestimmten Höhe.
Ah, Höhe ist auch ein Fall. Das heißt, es muss auch scheiße heiß sein sozusagen.
Nein, nicht unbedingt. Das ist eine sehr empfindliche Pflanze. Es muss eigentlich so ein ideales Klima sein, was auch das ideale Klima für Menschen ist. Also nicht zu heiß, nicht zu kalt, genug Wasser.
Das heißt, entweder da, wo viele Bäume sind, wo viel Wald auch noch ist oder muss es eine Hochlage sein?
Die Hochlage ist besser für den Geschmack des Kaffees, weil der dann süßer wird und komplexer im Geschmack.
Wie hoch ist diese Hochlage idealerweise?
Über 2000 Meter. 2000 Meter.
Gibt es aber in Malawi gar nicht so viele Orte, die glaube ich über 2000 Meter sind, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Ich war da nämlich mal. Die haben da zwar so ein paar Hochebenen, aber ich glaube die gehen gar nicht so hoch. Da ist der Kaffee auch nicht so gut. Weiß nicht, hast du schon mal Kaffee aus Malawi getrunken?
Ich habe schon mal Kaffee aus Malawi getrunken, ja. Der war auch eher erdig, muss ich sagen.
Und haben die denn alle sozusagen, gibt es verschiedene Kaffee-Pflanzen?
Es gibt verschiedene Kaffee-Pflanzen, das ist ganz interessant. Also was halt vielleicht jeder wissen sollte, es gibt Robusta arabica. Robusta wurde später entdeckt als Arabica. Arabica ist sozusagen die Kaffee-Uhrpflanze, ist geschmacklich überlegen, ist auch schwieriger anzubekommen.
Was ist die Originalpflanze? Die Arabica.
Die Arabica müsste ja eigentlich Äthiopie heißen.
Ja, aber die Araber waren halt die ersten, die überhaupt Handelsnamen eingeführt haben, nehme ich mal an.
Genau.
Sehr geschäftstüchtig. Okay, Arabica.
Und dann gibt es Robusta, das wurde früher später entdeckt. Und Robusta wächst halt niedriger, ist leichter anzubauen, hat einen höheren Ertrag, schmeckt allerdings auch nicht so gut wie Arabica.
Kommt das dann auch aus Äthiopien?
Das wurde als erstes entdeckt, glaube ich, im Uganda oder Kongo.
Kaffee, Afrika. Und das heißt, das heißt, alles, was heute sozusagen als wohlschmeckender Kaffee daherkommt, ist in der Regel Arabica. Kann man das so sagen?
Also für mich persönlich ja.
Wenn man so eine reine Sorte hat, aber wenn man jetzt so ein, keine Ahnung, ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man jetzt so eine Kaffeetüte, Jakobs Kaffee kauft, ist das dann überhaupt noch eine Sorte oder ist das schon so wie beim Tee dann so eine Mischung?
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine Mischung, weil die ein bestimmtes Geschmacksprofil haben und das ist ja Naturprodukt-Kaffee und es gibt Erntezeiten, es gibt, manchmal ist eine Ernte gut, manchmal nicht, also da wird halt viel gemischt.
Allein so aus Geschmacksgründen? Zumutungen sozusagen, weil man kann ja den Kunden nicht zumuten, dass es irgendwann mal anders schmeckt als sonst. Okay, das heißt und Arabica ist auch immer gleich Arabica oder gibt es dann jetzt sozusagen auch so Zucht-Erfolge, dass die dann sehr unterschiedlich sind?
Es gibt ganz verschiedene Varietäten, was jetzt zum Beispiel, also der der letzte Schrei ist sozusagen, ist eine Varietät, die heißt, also auf Englisch Varietal, die heißt Geisha und die schmeckt komplett anders als andere Kaffees. Da wurde letztes Jahr ein Rekordpreis dafür bezahlt, also für ein Kilogramm Rohkaffee 130 Dollar, was unglaublich viel ist.
130 Dollar für ein Kilo rohe Bohnen.
Also es war der höchste Preis, der jemals ein Rohkaffee war.
Was kostet normalerweise so Kaffee? Was ist so der normalen Preis?
Als Rohkaffee-Preis zwischen 2 bis 10 Euro.
Okay, also das 20-fache. Und was heißt Roh? Also der ist noch nicht geröstet?
Der ist noch nicht geröstet, grüne Bohnen.
Grüne Bohnen. Einfach so wie er vom Stauch fällt, sozusagen.
Nee, der ist dann schon bearbeitet. Also man muss sich vorstellen, das sind diese Kaffee-Kirchen, die werden dann entpullt, das heißt das Fruchtfleisch wird weggenommen. Und entweder man lässt das eine Weile fermentieren und wäscht das dann. Das ist der Water-Process, das ist gewaschene Arabika. Und dann noch mal getrocknet und noch mal gescheht, das ist noch so ein dünnes Häutchen drum, das muss auch noch weg. Oder es wird, also wie in Afrika, wo es nicht so viel Wasser gibt, es wird dann oder in Brasilien wird es zum Beispiel getrocknet und dann wird das Fruchtfleisch abgenommen.
Was ist denn eigentlich die Bohne? Also das ist sozusagen der Kern dieser Kaffee-Kirsche.
Genau.
Ist da auch der Samen dann drin oder ist das irgendwie einfach nur so ein Stein, der sich da so in der Evolution entwickelt hat?
Das ist eigentlich wie, was kann man das am besten vergleichen? Also das ist halt diese Kaffee-Kirsche und das ist eigentlich wie, weißt du, die Samen in einem Apfel.
Also das ist schon der Samen sozusagen?
Ja, das ist der Samen.
Daraus zieht man die Pflanze. Das heißt, man könnte auch irgendwie so die frischen Bohnen nehmen, wieder in die Erde schmeißen, dann wachsen da neue Pflanzen drauf. Und das heißt, um jetzt wirklich, können wir mal drauf kommen, wie man jetzt sozusagen, also was, was wird denn normalerweise gemacht? Also der Kaffee wächst jetzt in diesen Anbaugebieten, aber bevor er wirklich auf Reisen geht, wird er eigentlich schon vorbereitet. Du hast ja eben schon gesagt, also man nimmt jetzt sozusagen die Bohnen, also das ist ja gar keine Bohnen, man sagt ja immer nur Bohnen, also diesen Kern raus, den Rest schmeißt man weg. Oder was, was, was, was, ich, was man damit macht. Und dann wird er gewaschen.
Nein. Meistens wird er gewaschen, aber es gibt auch Verarbeitungsmethoden, da wird er nicht gewaschen, da wird er nur getrocknet. Und was ganz wichtig ist, er wird sortiert. Das heißt nach Größe und es gibt auch viele Defekte und das beeinflusst ganz stark auch die Kaffeequalität. Das heißt, da sind dann ganz viel fleißige Hände und suchen dann zum Beispiel die überreifenen Kaffeesamen heraus, Kaffeebohnen oder die mit Insektenfras.
Wie erkennt man an einer Farbe, wenn die überreif sind?
Ja, die erkennt man an einer Farbe oder eben es gibt Wassertanks und dann sehen sie, die haben auch verschiedene Dichten, die setzen sich dann ab. Die unreifen, die sind dann leichter als die reifen und da gibt es dann verschiedene Prozesse, um zu gewährleisten, dass man verschiedene Sortierungen hat.
Das heißt, das macht auch schon mal ganz erheblich, was für die Qualität des Endprodukts aus, diese Auswahl.
Unbedingt. Also man sagt, die Kaffeekirsche muss reif sein, damit du eine gute Tasse Kaffee daraus machen kannst, damit du wirklich die gesamte Geschmacksvielfalt von Kaffee erleben kannst. Nun ist das natürlich so, das ist eine immer grüne Pflanze und du hast immer gleichzeitig reife, unreife, überreife Kaffeekirsche an dieser Pflanze und das ist unglaublich schwierig, auch für die Leute, die das pflücken, das so genau zu pflücken. Und oft ist das auch nicht möglich, da gibt es auch verschiedene Ernte. Also in Brasilien zum Beispiel wird das einfach nur abgestriffen vom Zweig und das wird dann alles hinterher sortiert per Hand oder mit Maschinen oder verschiedenen.
Mit dir anderen schütteln das oder was?
Und die anderen machen das wirklich mit der Hand, handgepflückt und das ist auch das Besondere zum Beispiel bei unserem Kaffee. Unsere Kaffeebohnen wurden alle handgepflückt. Das ist unglaublich viel Arbeit und Sorgfalt.
Aber das bringt was.
Das bringt auf jeden Fall was. Also wenn du einmal...
Weil gar nicht erst die falschen gepflückt werden oder weil...
Also das Besondere bei der Kaffeepflanze ist, oder bei diesem Kaffeesamen, dass der anders als andere Pflanzen, der die Zellwände sehr viel dicker sind. Und dadurch, dass die Zellwände sehr viel dicker sind, funktioniert die einzelne Kaffeebohne wie ein Mini-Reaktor, wenn du anfängst, das zu rösten. Das heißt, da ist noch ein Rest Wasser drin, da sind Zucker drin, da sind Aminosäuren drin und alles mögliche Zeug. Und wenn das beim Rösten anfängt zu dampfen, findet eine Reaktion statt und die einzelne Kaffeebohne funktioniert als Reaktor. Das kann so viel Druck aushalten, dass dann diese Komponenten miteinander reagieren. Und dadurch entwickelt sich diese komplexe Aromavielfalt von Kaffee. Und das ist das Besondere an Kaffee. Wenn du jetzt aber eine unreife Kaffeebohne pflögst und hasst, dann sind die Zellwände zu dünn und dann findet dieser Prozess gar nicht statt.
Das heißt, okay, alles klar. Also dieser Reifeprozess ist einfach wichtig, damit dieser Röstvorgang auch so stattfinden kann, dass sich ja wirklich der Geschmack herausbildet, den man so braucht. Aber wenn wir jetzt nochmal zu Zeug an den Anfang gehen hier so, der Ziegenhörte, der sich da irgendwie sozusagen direkt an der Pflanze berauscht hat, also das wirkt sozusagen auch so schon. Klar, es ist Koffein drin, dann eben ohne den Geschmack. Das heißt, wie schmeckt denn eine ungeröstete Kaffeebohne?
Eine ungeröstete Kaffeebohne kann man eigentlich gar nicht essen, weil die so hart ist, wie so ein Stein, also wie so ein Stück Horn. Also du würdest dir die Zähne ausbeißen da dran eigentlich.
Was haben dann die Ziegen da gemacht? Die haben das einfach nur geschluckt?
Ich glaube, die haben eher die Kirschen gegessen und die grüne Bohnen dann geschluckt.
Dann hat sich das irgendwie so über die Zeit aufgelöst.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob auch Koffein in dem Fruchtfleisch ist. Das könnte natürlich auch sein.
Oder der Kern hat sich dann halt irgendwie im Magen aufgelöst und dann wird das dann so langsam abgebildet.
Es gibt ja auch diese Kaffeekatze, hast du schon von der gehört? Ja, das ist auch ein sehr teurer Kaffee, heißt Kopi Luak. In Indonesien gibt es so, die sehen ganz verrückt aus, das sind so Meerkatzen. Und die wandern durch die Kaffeeplantate und picken sich auch immer nur die reifsten Kaffeekirschen heraus, essen die dann, verdauen das und kommt halt hinten wieder raus.
Was meinst du jetzt mit Meerkatzen? Ich meine, Meerkatzen sind Affen.
Also es ist so eine Mischung, also man sagt zu der Katze, Kaffeekatze, aber das sind so Tiere, das sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Katze, aber die Augen sind halt hier.
Ist das der hier? Ich hab hier gerade mal ein bisschen in den Müllhalter nachgeschlagen. Also das ist ein Affe.
Also die Meerkatze. Okay, nee, nee, sieht schon anders aus.
Das sind nicht die mit der Kaffeekatze. Gucken wir mal, was die Kaffeekatze macht. Ähm, machen wir Kopiluwak.
Da ist sie.
Ah, der Fleckenmusang.
So, so.
So heißt das Gerät.
Schleichkatzenabend.
Eine Kaffeekatze. Okay, das ist eine spezielle Katzen-Kaffee sozusagen.
Ja, und die scheißen es halt aus und der Kaffee schmeckt halt, ist halt sehr intensiv und nachgeschmackt.
Eine sogenannte Schleichkatze. Verstehe. Und die fressen dann sozusagen die Kaffee-Kirschen und kacken die da aus. Und das wird dann eingesammelt, oder was?
Das wird dann eingesammelt.
Das ist also ein Pre-Process durch diese Katze.
Ja, das ist dann super naturfermentiert, ganz biologisch.
Das ist dieser Kopi Luwak.
Das ist dieser Kopi Luwak, der ist auch sehr bekannt. Also ich hab jetzt vor kurzem mit einem alten Röster gesprochen. Der meint, es finden ganz schlimme Sachen statt, weil die Indoneser, man kann damit so viel Geld machen. Also das ist halt ein Raritäten-Kaffee. Und das hat diese ganze Story dahinter, dass die Armkatzen eingefangen werden und dann mit in Käfigen gehalten werden.
Und den ganzen Tag diese Bodenfressen.
Wir hatten das mal ausprobiert. Es ist interessant. Man macht die Tüte auf, es riecht nach Zoo. Und hat wirklich einen ganz langen Nachgeschmack. Also man hat schon ein komisches Gefühl. Weil man weiß ja, welchen Weg.
Weiß ja gar ja, ob der Hirte dann sozusagen auch die Ziegen hat erstmal die Bohnen für sich vorbereiten lassen.
Dann war er wahrscheinlich ganz schlau.
Wir können nicht blicken in die Geschichte und die Gemüter äthiopischer Ziegenhirten. Aber jetzt noch mal zu dem Herstellungsprozess. Man pflückt die Kirsche vorsichtig, damit man eine möglichst reine Auslese hat von Kaffee-Kirschen, die einfach in dem richtigen Reife-Zustand sind. Dieser richtige Reife-Zustand sichert, dass die Wand dieser Kaffee-Bohne die richtige Dicke hat, sodass in dem Moment, wo man dann Hitze zuführt, also die Bohne röstet, dass dann innerhalb dieser Bohne genau dieser chemische Cocktail abläuft, der dann zusätzlich zu dem Koffein, was sowieso schon drin ist und was auch wirkt, wenn man es frisst, dann eben einfach diesen typischen aromatischen Geschmack erzeugt, den man gerne hätte.
Wunderbar.
Und wie muss man das, also was heißt rösten? Also wird das dann irgendwie in so einen Ofen geschoben oder läuft das dann so, keine Ahnung?
Also in Äthiopien wird es auf der Pfanne so gebraten. In Vietnam auch. Wir benutzen Röster.
Also eine schicke Röstmaschine sozusagen.
Eine schicke alte Röstmaschine haben wir bei uns.
Stimmt, die habt ihr irgendwie im Laden sogar.
Im Laden von 1930 hat uns der Orenkel von demjenigen, der diese Röstfirma aufgemacht hat, hat uns verscherbelt, der brauchte Kohle. Also das muss man sich vorstellen wie so eine Art Wäschetrommel mit einem Gasbrenner unten drunter. Und das dreht sich dann so hübsch. Also ganz vereinfacht, ja. Da gibt es einen Luftzug, das wird dann heiß gemacht und dann gibt es so eine ideale Rostkurve für jeden Kaffee, wo er dann ein Optimum erreicht an Geschmacksvielfalt und Aromavielfalt.
Rostkurve heißt, man hat jetzt auch nicht dauerhaft dieselbe Temperatur, sondern so über die Zeit muss man dieser Bohne unterschiedliche Temperaturen zuführen, damit sie irgendwie ordentlich vor sich hingedeiht.
Ja, das ist dann natürlich die Kunst des Röstens. Also wie man das genau macht und was für eine Rostkurve da sind, die röst da sehr... also das ist eher dann so ein Geheimnis. Das ist also wie so ein Rezept, was du hast.
Weil dann kann man sozusagen auch alles nochmal komplett versauen.
Komplett. Also das ist sowieso das Tollste an Kaffee. An jeder Stufe kann man alles Mögliche versauen. Also es fängt bei der Pflanze an, es ist eine unglaublich sensible Pflanze. Es dauert drei bis vier Jahre, bis die überhaupt irgendwelche Früchte trägt. Bei der Sortierung, bei der Ernte kann so viel schief gehen. Beim Rohkaffee-Transport kann ganz viel schief gehen. Und dann beim Rösten auch. Und beim Kaffeemachen auch.
Aber jetzt so in der industriellen Kaffeeproduktion oder sagen wir mal überhaupt der Kaffeeproduktion, ist es schon üblich, dass man jetzt also vor Ort natürlich die Bohnen erstmal einsammelt und aber auch röstet. Das heißt, der Kaffee geht ja schon geröstet unterwegs oder wird eher der Rohkaffee transportiert?
Also was zum Beispiel in Italien ist, die haben riesige Industrie-Röstanlagen oder auch woanders, wo immer auch, oder wo immer in großen Mengen Kaffee geröstet wird, der wird eingekauft und der wird zusammengemischt. Also verschiedene Qualitäten werden zusammengemischt.
Das heißt, man bezieht Rohkaffee?
Man bezieht Rohkaffee.
Generell, immer?
Ja.
Oder gibt es auch den Fall, dass schon vor Ort geröstet wird oder wäre das eigentlich Quatsch?
Nein, das ist Quatsch, weil Kaffee frische ganz wichtig ist und sobald der Kaffee geröstet ist, hat man ein Problem damit, die Frische zu gewährleisten und es zu lagern.
Verstehe.
Und Rohkaffee hält sich, es ist gut für ein Jahr und vielleicht sogar noch länger. Also wenn man einen sehr alten Rohkaffee hat, dann wird er gern verkauft als Vintage oder als Aged Sumatra oder Monsoon Malabar. Das hält sich einfach besser, es besser zu transportieren. Sobald es geröstet wird, muss man das eigentlich schnell verbrauchen.
Okay, also er wird halt eingesammelt und dann wird er irgendwie von der Kirsche getrennt, bleibt sozusagen die Bohnen übrig und die wird dann nochmal gewaschen oder auch nicht. Genau, sortiert und das ist dann der Zeitpunkt, wo es dann in die Kiste kommt und dann geht es irgendwie auf Reisen. Und ab da geht es dann irgendwie in den eigentlichen Produktionsort, in eurem Fall. Also ihr kauft sozusagen auch Rohkaffee ein.
Ja, also da gibt es noch ziemlich viele Mittelmänner dazwischen. Meistens ist dann halt ein Importer, der dann Container lädt, also mit diesem Rohkaffee. Und der dann halt ja, also dann kommt der Röster dorthin, probiert die Rohkaffeeproben und der sagt dann, ok, ich möchte so und so viel Säcke von Jigarchef aus dieser Region und ich kauf das zu dir in den Preis. Dann wird das halt geliefert und geröstet. Das machen wir auch, aber in sehr kleinen Mengen noch.
Das heißt, du fährst jetzt wirklich irgendwo hin, wo sozusagen der Rohkaffee aufschlägt. Wo ist das?
In Deutschland ist das Hamburg.
Generell?
Generell, ja. Kaffee Hamburg, sowieso Hamburg für Europa ist ganz wichtig. Es ist ein Kaffeehafen, da wird sehr viel gehandelt. Da sind viele Importe auch für die kommerziellen Kaffees. Das ist auch der Sitz der Neumann-Gruppe.
Der Dabo. Ja, diese ganzen bekannten deutschen Kaffee-Leute.
Die sitzen halt auch alle in Hamburg.
Das heißt, du fährst wirklich dahin? Aber nicht jede Woche oder so?
Wir haben ja jetzt auch erst angefangen, wir wussten einfach, diese Importer sind gut. Ich hoffe, der Zoll hört jetzt gerade nicht mit. Der war heute bei uns an der Tür. Ja, guck dir ganz ernst. Man muss ja Kaffee-Steuer bezahlen. Wir sind noch einmal herumexperimentieren. Unsere Espresso-Bundi, die du bei uns trinkst, die lassen wir beim großen Röster rösten. Wir haben jetzt unseren kleinen Röster, den hast du bei uns im Laden gesehen. Der ist eigentlich ein Boutique-Röster. Und eigentlich dazu da zu designen.
Um sozusagen neue Röstmethoden herauszufinden. Aber eigentlich lasst ihr rösten.
Eigentlich lassen wir rösten.
Aber trotzdem gab es schon mal den Zeitpunkt, wo ihr auch eure Qualitäten vorsortiert habt. Das heißt, du bist nach Hamburg gefahren und hast dann eine Test-Röstung teilgenommen. Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Nein, das nicht. Wir haben den einfach blind gekauft, wussten aber, die haben eine gewisse Qualität. Wir konnten schon an den Namen sehen und so weiter.
Hast du eine Rohr gekauft oder geröstet gekauft?
Rohr gekauft und dann Probe geröstet. Dann in eurer Maschine. Probe geröstet und zu sehen, was kann dieser Kaffee machen, was kann man benutzen. Wenn wir eine neue Mischung machen, welche Komponenten können wir jetzt zusammenbringen? Wie muss der Kaffee am besten geröstet werden? Weil der Röststil in Deutschland auch immer noch relativ dunkel ist. Für unseren Geschmack sollten die Terroir-Qualitäten des Kaffees in Vordergrund sein durch das Rösten. Du hast verschiedene Geschmackskomponenten in der Kaffeebühne. Was den Geschmack ausmacht, was von der Pflanze kommt. Das heißt Enzymatic By-Products auf Englisch. Was kommt wirklich von der Pflanze selbst, während sie dort wächst? Das sind meist Fruchtnoten, florale Noten oder Gewürznoten. Manchmal kann der Kaffee auch nach grünen Bohnen und Erbsen schmecken. Oder nach Karottensuppe, das hatten wir heute auch.
Karottensuppe?
Karottensuppe Original oder Miso. Das ist alles Enzymatic By-Products. Dann hast du diesen gesamten Geschmacksteil, der eigentlich Caramelisation-Process ist.
Caramelisierung, was durch das Rösten beursacht wird.
Genau, und das ist, wenn die Zucker im Kaffee schmelzen und dann so Süße entwickeln.
Das eine ist sozusagen, was die Pflanzen mitbringen, das andere ist, was man dann durch den Röstprozess hinzufügt.
Das sind dann Geschmacknoten wie Nuss, also Mandel, Erdnuss, Haselnuss oder zum Beispiel Caramel, Toffee.
Nennst du das jetzt nur so oder schmeckt das dann auch tatsächlich so?
Das schmeckt dann auch so. Oder Schokolade und dann verschiedene Abstufungen von Schokolade.
Das kann man alles nur dadurch beeinflussen, dass man einerseits die richtige Quelle nimmt, also den richtigen Rohstoff, aber dann eben einfach an dieser Röstkurve so lange rumzappelt oder was. Dass man sagt, wenn ich jetzt hier mit einer hohen Temperatur einsteige und dann lasse ich es langsam abklingen, dann ist es irgendwie mehr Walnuss. Oder wenn ich irgendwie mit einer niedrigen Temperatur mache und zwischendurch gebe ich ihm noch so zwei Schockwellen.
Du wärst der perfekte Röster. Also wie schön, wenn du anfängst darüber zu reden. Und dann würde es zum Beispiel auch so anfangen, der Kaffee aus der Region, der hat halt nicht diese Sweetberry, also Süßbeerennoten, sondern eher so Richtung Erdig. Das könnte ich ja noch mit etwas dunkleren Röstung verstärken. Und das könnte ich dann ja mischen mit einem Afrikaner, der ganz fruchtig ist und Erdbeerennoten hat.
Was heißt dunkle Röstung, dass man sozusagen lange unter Feuer setzt, dass es irgendwie so richtig schwarz wird, die Bohne?
So richtig schwarz soll es nicht werden, dann schmeckt es halt wie Asche.
Klar, irgendwann ist es verbrannt.
Irgendwann ist es verbrannt, ja klar. Das wird dann noch French Roast genannt. Das ist sehr polar bei Starbuck. Die Franzosen machen das. Aber die hatten so schlechten Kaffee, da mussten die das machen.
Woanders...
Ich glaube, die hatten viel robust angebaut, die Franzosen.
Was für Temperaturen sind denn das? Was für Temperaturen herrschen denn dann so in dem Apparat?
In dem Roaster bis maximal 230 Grad, maximal.
Und minimal?
Und minimal, also die ersten Reaktionen fangen an mit 60 Grad. Also das ist wirklich was mit der Bohne, das sie anfängt, Feuchtigkeit abzugeben.
so zwischen 60 und maximal 230 Grad, da zwischendurch macht man sich dann sozusagen so eine Verlaufskurve. Wie lange röstet dann so eine Dosis?
Also bei uns zwischen 12 und 15 Minuten, das ist die Langzeitröstung. Die ist halt auch wichtig, weil die Bohne auch Zeit braucht, um durch diesen Prozess zu gehen. Also was ich vorhin erklärt habe mit diesem kleinen Kernreaktor, bei der Industrieröstung, die arbeiten mit höheren Temperaturen bis 350 Grad und der ist dann in zwei bis drei Minuten fertig.
Verstehe, muss schnell gehen, wir haben keine Zeit.
Und dann ist es meistens außen zwar braun, aber innen noch nicht ganz gar.
Das heißt, das Geheimnis liegt eher in der sanften Herbeiführung dieses Karamellisierungsprozesses und da kann dann sozusagen der Röstdesigner seine volle Kreativität entfalten.
Ja, und er muss natürlich mit der Bohnen zusammenarbeiten, was sie auch hergibt. Also du kannst nicht aus einer schlecht sortierten Sumatra-Lington, wo die Ernte halt schlecht war, weil es war zu feucht und zu viele Insekten, kannst du jetzt nicht einen super Kaffee rausdrehen. Kannst du das Beste draus machen?
Ist das dann auch so wie beim Wein, dass man dann sagt, ah, irgendwie jetzt so hier 2005 war Sumatra viel zu feucht, aber jetzt gehen wir noch mal hier auf Äthiopien 2007 mal, eine tolle Note.
Also ich hab vor zwei Tagen halt auch mit dem alten Roster von uns gesprochen, und er hat gesagt, ah ja, der Sumatra, der ist dieses Jahr echt nichts gebrauchen, und vor drei Jahren war der super, und jetzt muss ich einen anderen Kaffee kaufen.
Verstehe.
Ist halt ein Naturprodukt, das hängt immer ab.
Klar, aber mir war das nicht so bewusst, dass das da so starken Schwankungen ausgesetzt ist.
Es ist ein unglaublich komplex Kaffee.
Gibt es denn dann auch beim Tee, beim Tee gibt es ja diese absurden Qualitätsbezeichnungen, TG, FOP, tralala, gibt es da auch so einen Code, um diese Geschmacksnote auch in irgendeiner Form zu abstrahieren, und dass man das so am Namen erkennen kann, weil man könnte ja jetzt vielleicht nicht immer genau so wie Sumatra Nord oder so.
Ja, also es gibt, die einzelnen Länder haben ihre Qualitätsstufen, also zum Beispiel Kenia AA ist dann die größte Bohne, also am besten sortiert, oder dann gibt es Kenia AA und Kenia AB, oder es gibt Santos II, oder also jedes Land hat für sich nochmal welche, dann gibt es eine nummerische, wie sagt man dazu, eine Einteilung, Klassifizierung, genau, also dann sind professionelle Verkoster dort, die den Kaffee probieren und genau heraus schmecken können, okay, der hat jetzt Defekte oder der lag auf der Strasse, auf der Teerstrasse, ich kann jetzt ganz deutlich Gummi schmecken, das ist nicht so gut, also da werden erstmal 10 Punkte abgezogen.
Gummi?
Ja, das kommt auch häufig vor, das wird ja, Kaffee muss ja getrocknet werden, also es wird gepflückt, wird getrocknet, muss man vorstellen, das ist halt dann irgendwo und dann ist es vielleicht so eine geteerte Straße und dann wird es da halt…
Verstehe, das halt einfach dann auch die Umwelt aufnimmt. Liegt rum, irgendwie, verstehe.
Manchmal ist diese Geschmacksnote so stark wie bei dem Monsoon Malabar, dass es sich durchsetzt und da war das eben so, dass der Monsoon Malabar hat einen ziemlich weiten Weg.
Das ist eine Marke jetzt?
Das ist jetzt eine Sorte, genau, aus Indonesien. Und das war halt immer in feuchter Umgebung und in diesen Kaffeesäcken. Dadurch hat es einen ganz, das schmeckt halt so nach Kaffeesack. Und das finden manche Leute toll. Und die waren dann ganz, also und dann, wollte man nie qualitiert sein, aber dann schmeckt es ja nicht mehr nach diesem Monsoon Malabar.
Das heißt, obwohl es eigentlich nach Kaffeesack schmeckte.
Genau, nach feuchten Kaffeesack. Ich will jetzt die Leute nicht... Also es gibt viele, die das richtig gern mögen.
Okay, aber es ist natürlich klar und offensichtlich, alles hat irgendwie Einfluss. Das Ding ist einfach eine Geschmackspflanze, die hat so diesen kleinen Geschmacksträsor da drin. Und wenn man da irgendwie komisch kommt, dann protestiert sie und schmeckt einfach anders. Wenn ich nicht richtig behandelt werde, dann schmeck ich auch nicht.
Ja, die ist ganz zickig.
Wie mosig fast.
Und das fängt ja beim Rösten an. Also beim Rösten kann man ganz viel falsch machen.
Aber noch mal kurz zu diesem Code. Aber es gibt jetzt keine international verbindliche Bezeichnung für Geschmack in dem Sinne.
Doch, es gibt ein Verkostungsprotokoll. Das wird viel von Importern benutzt oder auch von Röstern. Und da geht man eben durch die einzelnen, was beim Kaffee viel mehr ist als beim Wein zum Beispiel, ist Aroma. Also das Interessanteste am Kaffee ist das Aroma, die Aromavielfalt, was durch die Nase aufgenommen wird. Und das wird dann beurteilt, ist das jetzt floralfruchtig oder eben eher in die Richtung Gewürze oder Gemüse. Und das wird dann festgehalten und auch bewertet, numerisch aber auch mit kleinen Kommentaren, okay, das riecht jetzt ganz schön nach Erdbeere oder nach Bergamot und hat so einen, riecht noch nach Muskatnuss.
Das kann alles im Kaffee drin sein?
Das kann alles im Kaffee drin sein. Das ist unglaublich, also vor zwei Wochen hatten wir eine Verkostung und dann haben wir alle Bananenbrot und wir haben das zusammen mit einem Japaner gemacht. Meine Eltern kommen aus Korea und wir waren Miso-Suppe. Original Miso-Suppe.
Okay, also Kaffee und Miso, das hätte ich jetzt nicht so unweitig zusammengebracht. Aber ich weiß nicht, muss man denn da eigentlich eine besondere Gabe haben? Menschen sind ja sehr unterschiedlich mit den Geschmackselektoren. Bist du so ein Superschmecker?
Ich bin kein Superschmecker, ich bin normal, aber als Frau ist man ein bisschen sensibler. Deswegen sollten die Verkoster, tendiert man jetzt so weibliche Verkoster zu nehmen, weil sie doch ein bisschen mehr schmeckensensibler sind. Das nicht, aber man kann ein optimales Geruchsgedächtnis aufbauen. Das geht jetzt zu maximal 10.000. Wir jetzt bewusst erkennen, können wir vielleicht bis zu 10.000 verschiedene Gerüche.
Gerüche oder Geschmäcker oder beides?
Nein, Geschmäcker sind süß-sauer-salzig. Das gibt es auch beim Kaffee, das wird auch bewertet. Aber was beim Kaffee interessant ist, dass es alles mit dem Geruch zu tun hat.
Das heißt, man ist eigentlich mehr die ganze Zeit zu riechen?
Riechen, aber auch während man schluckt, eröffnen sich diese nasalen Membrane. Während man schluckt, das im Mund hat, nimmt man das eigentlich über die Nase auf.
Aber um das zu vergleichen, muss man im Prinzip dann auch die alle identisch aufbrühen. Gibt es da so eine definierte Methode, wie man das jetzt brüht, um das vergleichen zu können?
Ja, das nennt man Cupping oder Verkostung. Das macht vielleicht jede Firma ein bisschen anders auch, aber es ist eigentlich so, man malt Kaffee, immer die gleiche Menge, hat überall den gleichen Röstgrad und gießt einfach heißes Wasser drüber.
Also Röstgrad, in einigen Worten, man nimmt einfach nur eine Temperatur und eine definierte Zeit.
Um dann möglichst, also dann die verschiedenen Kaffees möglichst ohne den Röstgeschmack, der noch dazu kommt, schmecken zu können, das machen die Leute, die halt Rohkaffee einkaufen, damit die wissen, okay, wenn ich jetzt einen Container davon kaufe, nicht, dass der jetzt, dass er zu lange fermentiert worden ist oder dass da überreife Bohnen drin sind, die stinker heißen und dann eine ganze Ladung versauen können.
Da hat die Zellmembran schon die richtige Dicke, aber die sind dann irgendwie anderweitig vergangen.
Ja, da wurde das Innere dann aufgegessen von Schimmeln und Bakterien.
Okay, das heißt, mit diesem Cupping, das heißt, jeder Röster behält dann sozusagen seine Methode bei und dadurch werden dann die Ergebnisse auch vergleichbar. Haben die dann irgendwie so Superschmecker am Start? Das sind irgendwie so Leute, Superschmecker, sind ja diese Leute, die jetzt so besonders viele Geschmacksknospen haben und die einfach nochmal so ein ganz...
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass ein Superschmecker zu sein gar nicht so gut ist, weil die Mehrheit deiner Kunden sind nicht Superschmecker. Und Superschmecker sind halt sehr, sehr sensibel. Und das könnte schon fast... Zu viel sein, man will ja so einen gewissen...
Was denkst du, wie viel Gerüche und Geschmäcke du so auseinanderhalten kannst?
Immer mehr.
Man wird besser?
Man wird besser. Und das ist eben auch das Ding. Jeder kann es lernen, das ist eine Sache des Trainings. Und man kann, also man sagt, also man bewusst unterscheiden kann man jetzt so normal Bürger so 5000, aber man kann bis zu 10.000 und das ist einfach nur lernen.
Echt, ich kann 5000 verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen unterscheiden?
Gerüche.
Das ist eine Möglichkeit. Und wie klassifizierst du so dann so einen Kaffee, wenn du den dann so verkostest? Also du hast ja schon gesagt, es ist so ein bisschen fruchtig, so ein bisschen gewürzig, riecht nach Gemüseladen. Ist das wirklich so die Methode, mit der du das dann auch niederschreibst?
Ja, wir haben dann so Protokolle. Und da ist das noch mal ein bisschen differenzierter noch. Also dann könnte man sagen, okay, das ist jetzt wie Cranberry oder wie Himbeere oder wie Schwarze-Johannes-Beere. Oder hier habe ich jetzt geröstete Mandeln. Oder das ist jetzt hier ganz eindeutig Gurke.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst? Also wirklich im Sinne von, dass ein Kaffee genauso schmeckt wie eine Gurke schmeckt?
Oder riecht das gut? Also Komponenten von Gurke hat es, ja.
Komponenten von Gurke?
War interessant. Also was man auch im Kaffee hat, ist z.B. Beef, also Fleisch, oder Smoked Beef, oder dass man so Pfeifentabak als Geruch ganz stark wahrnimmt. Es gibt auch eher unangenehme Sachen. Also wir haben ziemlich hochwertige Kaffees, deswegen werden wir nicht ganz so auch häufig damit konfrontiert. Das geht dann ins medizinische ab. Also am Anfang waren viele Kaffees untrinkbar, also was ich vorhin meinte mit Gummi, oder medizinisch, oder man will es gleich wieder ausspucken.
Es schmeckt nach Hustensaft irgendwie.
Ja z.B. Hustensaft oder es kann...
So ein Kaffee schafft es einfach nicht, der wird dann nicht qualifiziert.
Der darf dann nicht in den Röster rein. Aber z.B. heute eben auch hatten wir halt so ein bisschen Muskatnuss in dem einen Kaffee.
Das heißt, ihr habt jetzt in eurem Laden auch so permanente Varietät irgendwie. Der Kaffee schmeckt jeden Tag ein bisschen anders?
Na wir haben jetzt so ein bisschen so eine Zweiteinigung. Also unser Kaffee sozusagen für sich ist ja so ein Showroom und wir haben angefangen mit Espresso, mit einer Espresso-Mischung. Das ist eine ganz andere Kultur, sag ich mal. Und das läuft noch nie mehr. Aber währenddessen bilden wir uns halt weiter und wollen, weil wir das persönlich einfach auch am interessantesten finden. Also ohne jetzt schlecht über Espresso ist eine tolle Sache. Aber diese sogenannten Raritäten-Cafés oder Single-Origin-Cafés, eben mit diesen ganzen Aspekten, dass du dir bewusst wirst, ok, der Kaffee wurde dort und dort angebaut. Das ist die Unterart von so und so. Und das war vom Farmer Paolo am Südhang. Es ist halt interessant, wenn man Sachen vergleichen kann. Und auch ganz verschiedene Charaktere. Wir hoffen, dass wir die irgendwann mal anbieten können. Wir samplen jetzt ganz viel für uns. Aber dass man dann sagen kann, ich bin mehr in der Stimmung. So einen Kaffee könnte ich jeden Tag trinken. Das ist mir so ein intellektueller Kaffee. Der ist so ganz fein. Es gibt auch verschiedene Charaktere. Und ich glaube, die passen dann auch besser für verschiedene Leute und zu verschiedenen Tageszeiten.
Das heißt, zu euch kann man auch hingehen und kann sich sein Designer-Kaffee zusammenstellen lassen.
Hoffen wir bald, dass es so weit ist.
Das ist so das Ziel. Aber im Laden habt ihr sozusagen nur ein paar Sorten. Bleibt ihr dann irgendwie auch so mehr oder weniger konstant in eurem Geschmack, den ihr dann so verabreicht?
Also bei uns, also das, was ich jetzt, diese ganze Information, die ich jetzt gehe, die finden also alle ein bisschen Underground statt. Also wir sind mittwochs und donnerstags geschlossen und da bilden wir uns halt weiter und machen diese ganzen Verkostungen und machen diese Proberöstungen. Unser Ziel ist, dass dann irgendwann, also bald kann man unseren, erstens unseren Espresso kaufen. Das ist halt so ein Basic-Café, das kommt sehr gut mit Milchgetränken. Und dann möchten wir aber langsam also dann in Richtung Terroir-Café gehen und wo man das Rösten auch dementsprechend anpasst und wo man einfach eine Story auch zu erzählen hat zum einzelnen Kaffee.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir glaube ich mal so ein bisschen weg von der Bohne hin zu dem eigentlichen Ergebnis. Also wenn man jetzt sozusagen noch mal zusammenfasst, so man als Kaffee, ja wie nennt man denn das dann sozusagen? Ihr seid ja so ein bisschen die Zeremonienmeister. Also ihr bestimmt letzten Endes, wie der Geschmack ist. Ihr wählt aus, woher kommt der Kaffee, je nach irgendwie Jahresereignis aus unterschiedlichen Quellen und dann entscheidet man sich, ob man irgendwie eine reine Sorte nimmt oder ob man sogar mischt. So, dann kombiniert man das dann irgendwie mit dem angesagten Röstprofil sozusagen und dann erhält man eine neue Sorte. Oder einer, nein Sorte ist nicht der Richtige, aber eine Kaffeemischung. Oder wie nennt ihr das?
Ja, es ist ein bisschen wie der Winzer, der dann halt aus der ganz tollen, also er ist ein super Bauer und hat das angebaut, und dann ist aber noch die Kunst des Kelterns kommt dann noch dazu. Und was beim Kaffee noch dazu kommt, dass halt Wein nicht ist, ist noch, beim Wein, da ist dann, da weint vielleicht in der Flasche und dann brauchst du nur auszuschalten, kannst eigentlich nicht so viel falsch machen. Beim Kaffee aber beim Zubereiten, weil man muss das Getränk ja zubereiten, kann man auch nochmal so viele Fehler machen, dass es dann auch schon wieder eine Kunst ist, einen guten Kaffee zu machen. Und das ist also, mit dem wir halt angefangen haben, war mit Espresso. Und das ist halt eine neue Bewegung, wo neue wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse über Kaffee, wie sich Kaffee verhält, gegenüber Temperatur, dass das halt mit eingearbeitet worden ist, wie man den Kaffee zubereitet und wir das ein bisschen anders machen als andere Coffee-Shops.
Okay, aber ihr seid ja sozusagen die Kaffee-Kälterer. Ihr macht jetzt überhaupt erst mal, dass da sozusagen eine Sorte kommt, und ihr bestimmt auch den Röstgrad. Und dann hat man dann so die geröstete Bohnen, die kommt dann rein in die Malmaschine, dann hat man irgendwie seinen Pulver. Und jetzt ist ja die große Frage, wie kann man jetzt sozusagen dieses Produkt, das kurz bevor es jetzt wirklich zu einem Getränk wird, wie unterscheidet man das? Also du hast jetzt so Begriffe genannt wie Espresso, das kennt jeder irgendwie, auch wenn wahrscheinlich keiner genau weiß, was es eigentlich bedeutet. Und wie hieß das? Terroir?
Terroir-Café oder Single Origin-Café? Terroir.
Wie schreibst du das? T wie Terroir, wie geht's weiter?
Mit noch einem I zwischen dem O und dem R.
Ah, Terroir, alles klar.
Also, französisch das...
Ja, was heißt denn das?
Terroir, das ist nach dem Anbaugebiet oder wie das Mikroklimat ist, dort, wie der Boden dort ist, beschaffen ist. Kommt an die Erster-Wein-Sprache.
Wie die Erde sozusagen beschaffen ist, verstehe ich.
Auch eigentlich der Begriff Single-Origin ist eigentlich noch geläufiger. Hier steht es. Terroir wird eigentlich mehr verwendet in Bezug zu Wein. Also es gibt verschiedene Extraktionsmethoden.
Also bezieht sich jetzt Terroir auf eine bestimmte Art von Kaffeeprodukt, die man sozusagen erstellt. Also ein bestimmtes Bouquet, was dabei rauskommt. Oder hat es schon eher was mit den Sorten selber zu tun?
Also Terroir heißt eigentlich erst mal nur, dass man kleine Kaffee-Lots hat. Also kleine speziell sortierte Kaffee-Lots, wo man ganz genau identifizieren kann. Das kommt von diesem Hang dort. Eine Kiste mit Kaffee, so und so viel. Und dass man sagen kann, okay, das war an diesem Hang, wurde vom Pharma so und so produziert, können wir von A nach B zurückverfolgen, wo das genau herkommt. Und hat deswegen auch ein bestimmtes Geschmacksprofil. Alles, was in die Industrieröstung kommt, ist gemischt. Du weißt nicht, woher das kommt. Das wird als Massenfahrer in New York an der Kaffeebörse gehandelt und dort und hier und...
Aber euch steht es genauer drauf, wenn man möchte, kann man auch irgendwie in das ferne Land fahren und dann direkt an den Hang marschieren und dann die Bolognese...
Hallo, ich fand dein Kaffee super.
Man kann dann so Rituale abfeiern.
Das ist halt Terroir oder Single Origin Kaffee.
Dass man weiß, woher er kommt. Und was heißt dann Espresso?
Espresso ist eigentlich nur die Zubereitungsmethode durch die Espresso-Maschine. Das heißt, man benutzt Druck und heißt es Wasser, Kaffeeöl aus dem Kaffeepartikel, aus dem Kaffee-Mehl heraus.
Trotzdem gibt es auch schon diese Bezeichnung, dass es sich bei bestimmten Kaffeesorten um Espresso-Kaffee handelt. Es gibt jetzt bestimmte Kaffeesorten, die für bestimmte Zubereitungsmethoden optimiert sind.
Du kannst jede Kaffeebohne durch die Espresso-Maschine jagen. Aber man muss das Röstprofil anpassen. Weil, wenn du jetzt einen leichter gerösteten Kaffee hast, der vielleicht als, sagen wir mal, in der French Press sehr gut kommt, kann das sein, dass das im Espresso selbst, weil das ja sehr konzentriert ist, zu sauer wird.
French Press ist dieser Glasbehälter mit dem Teil, wo man einfach nur den Bodensatz nach unten hat, diese Bodum-Teile, genau. Das, was da funktioniert, muss nicht in der Espresso-Maschine funktionieren, weil es einfach dann dem Druck nicht standhält.
Es hält dem Druck stand, aber die...
Die Aromen entwickeln sich nicht in dieser Situation.
Die entwickeln sich anders. Das heißt, generell, du kannst den selben Kaffee haben, du kannst einen Single Origin Kaffee haben von Guatemala, Finca, Hernandez und so. Und du kannst den nehmen und sagen, ich röste den einmal als Espresso. Und dann kommt er auch super raus. Also ich möchte dann mehr schokoladige Noten eigentlich von diesem Guatemala und rosse den jetzt ein bisschen dunkler oder macht mit der Rostkurve das und das. Und du kannst sagen, ich möchte den aber auch als zweiter Kaffee benutzen, rösten. Da interessiert mich eigentlich mehr so die Säurebetonung und rosse das dementsprechend. Und Espresso ist entweder also, dass man nur den Espresso selbst trinkt und aber in Berlin, Deutschland, Europa, weltweit ist es oft auch verbunden in Kombination mit Milch. Und das ist natürlich eher säurebetonte Kaffees mit Milch kann gut schmecken, aber die Leute mögen dann doch lieber so schokoladigere Karamellennoten zusammen mit der Milch.
So, also nochmal. Ihr würdet ganz gerne mehr so Terroir-Kaffees machen, also sozusagen dieses Senior Origin.
Wir würden gerne mehr Terroir- und Senior Origin-Kaffee importieren. Am liebsten, wenn das jetzt die ideale Welt wäre, hätten wir ganz viele Direktkontakte zu den Produzenten, dann würden wir wissen, okay, wir haben total Transparenz, wir wissen, okay, das kommt vom Bauer so und so, das wird so und so angebaut. Deswegen hat das auch eine überdurchschnittliche Qualität, weil wir auch mit ihm kommunizieren, sagen können, hey, das ist ja super, aber bei der letzten Sortierung nimm doch die mit den Insektenbissen auch nochmal raus. Dann kriegen wir ein besseres Ergebnis. Und dann kriegen wir diesen Terroir-Kaffee oder diesen Single Origin-Kaffee. Und dann rösten wir ihn mit unserer Röstkunst optimal für die verschiedenen Zubereitungsmethoden.
Zum Beispiel. Zum Beispiel. Filter-Kaffee, was gibt es noch? French Press, was hast du gesagt?
French Press, Herdkennchen gibt es ja noch. Dann gibt es noch ganz neu die Clover. Aber das führt jetzt vielleicht zu weit.
Ach, hier führt nichts jemals zu weit. Was ist denn eine Clover?
Die Clover ist die erste Maschine, die einzelne Tassen schwarzen Kaffee frisch aufbrüht. Und das wurde entwickelt als Start-up-Unternehmen von Oxford. Woher kam die von Harvard oder so was? Stanford, keine Ahnung. Und was das Besondere an der Maschine war, sie war als erste Maschine für schwarzen Kaffee temperaturstabil. Das hat man herausgenommen, dass Temperaturstabilität ganz wichtig ist. Und man konnte jetzt so einen kleinen Computer und da konnte man dann halt eingeben, wie lange man das brühen möchte, wie viel rauskommen soll.
Das ist jetzt was brandneues. Die Maschine wurde vor kurzem erfunden.
Die wurde vor ein paar Jahren erfunden. Das war der totale Hype in dieser kleinen Kaffeeszene. Leider hat das dann Howard Schulz entdeckt und hat dann gleich die ganze Firma aufgekauft. Und seitdem gibt es die... Howard Schulz ist der Begründer von Starbucks. Also der... Nicht der Begründer, aber derjenige, der Starbucks zu dem gemacht hat, was es jetzt ist. Das waren ja davor so... Und dann war es schon wieder weg. Wir hatten dann das Glück oder Unglück, weiß nicht, noch eine zu ergattern. Ja, weil der Schritt ist noch ein bisschen zu groß, glaube ich, für die normalen Kaffeetrinker.
Die Welt ist noch nicht reif für Clover.
Die Welt ist noch nicht ganz reif für die Clover. Und wir vielleicht auch noch nicht ganz. Aber das kommt noch.
Verstehe.
Also das ist dann... Die macht halt eine ganz saubere Tasse. Das Ding mit der Clover ist... Howard Schulz hat die halt gekauft und wollte das halt für Starbucks. Aber das hat nicht so viel Sinn, weil die brüht so präzise und so sauber. Also weil die auch nur auf einer Temperatur bleibt, dass man nur 1A Kaffee dort reinmachen kann. Also so ein Starbucks-Kaffee ist einfach auch erstens von der Röstung, weil es ist ein Massenprodukt. Das ist so, als ob man einen Fasenhaus hat.
Warum hat er das dann gekauft? Wollte er das vom Markt haben?
Er wollte das vom Markt haben.
Ist das noch eine Verschwörungstheorie? Nö, es ist belebt durch Interviews.
Bei dieser neuen Kaffee-Bewegung, das sind eigentlich kleine Coffee-Shops, die das tragen, die teilweise sehr erfolgreich sind. Aber das ist sozusagen so eine Bewegung von unten. Das sind alles Leute aus einem kreativen Bereich, aus einem Musikbereich, aus einem Kunstbereich. Das sind alles kreative Leute, die Kaffee lieben.
Der Kaffeeuntergrund.
Der Kaffeeuntergrund, ja.
Die sich in unsere Höhen treffen, irgendwie unterirdisch, in ihren geheimen Kellern, mit ihren eigenen Röstmaschinen und irgendwie den Kaffee von übermacht machen.
Ja, und sich übers Internet austauschen. Dadurch ist es halt weltweit ziemlich zeitgleich dann überall aufgepackt, dass sie sehr miteinander verbunden sind. Wir haben Kontakt auch jetzt zu London und Seattle im Portland. Also man kennt sich so ein bisschen.
Verstehe. Und es gibt auch so richtig krasse Kaffeeforen, wo dann irgendwie diskutiert wird. Und ist das alles ganz geheim oder gibt es da irgendwie auch schon so bekannte Portale, die jetzt irgendwie um was man sich zum tunen kann?
Ja, da gibt es zum Beispiel, international ist es eher Coffeeed oder Too Much Coffee. Bei manchen Portalen muss man eingeladen werden. In Deutschland gibt es das Kaffee Netz. Womit wir aber... Kaffee Netz ist so eine Sache für sich. Also es ist manchmal nicht ganz so offen, nicht für neue Sachen.
Verstehe. Also das ist sozusagen nochmal so eine Subkultur, die man überhaupt nicht auf dem Radar hat, aber die sich auch das Internet zunutze macht. Und da ist einfach mal Kaffee in Bewegung. Gut, dann machen wir mal wieder eine Klammer schließen. Jetzt haben wir einen kleinen Clover-Verschwörungstheorie-Ausflug gemacht. Diese Zubereitung. Da sind wir jetzt irgendwie. Jetzt haben wir sozusagen unsere Kaffees. Bleiben wir vielleicht erstmal so beim Espresso, bei den Espresso-Maschinen, weil das ist ja nur eigentlich, würde ich sagen, einfach mal so die, zumindest derzeit so die populärste Form. Wenn man jetzt mal vom Filter-Café absieht, der wahrscheinlich so rein zahlenmäßig immer noch so der meistgebrühte ist. Wobei es ja auch immer so ein bisschen diesen Nimbus der Langeweile hat.
Es wieder zu Timecom.
Du siehst das anders. Okay, das finde ich interessant.
Aber ganz unter uns.
Ich habe mal gehört, dass die Italiener ganz verächtlich nach Deutschland schauen mit diesem Filter-Café. Und die nennen das irgendwie, also insbesondere diese besondere Art und Weise mit diesen Kaffeemaschinen, wo dann die ganze Zeit dieser Kaffee so lauwarmen oben irgendwie reintröpfelt. Da zieht sich ja auch irgendwie alles ein bisschen zusammen. Ich habe mal gehört, die nennen das Café Tedesco. Also einfach deutschen Kaffee oder sowas. Würden irgendwie nur Deutsche machen mit ihrer ganzen Stillosigkeit an der Stelle. Während der Italiener ja eigentlich immer nur von Kaffee spricht. Und wenn er Kaffee sagt, dann meint er wirklich diese tief schwarze, mit hohem Druck gebrühte Kaffee-Variante, die wir Espresso nennen. Aber die sozusagen nicht der Italiener nicht Espresso nennt, sondern das ist für ihn einfach Kaffee.
Also ich meine, die haben ja die Espressomaschine auch erfunden. Und Espresso heißt eigentlich einzeln für den Kunden hergestellt, also zubereitet. Und also wir haben ja auch noch mal so einen Italienausflug gemacht. Und ich glaube, das ist auch die einzige, also Federkaffee gibt es da einfach auch nicht.
Nee, das ist, nee, das ist für die auch, glaube ich, das ist für die ein Werk der Ungläubigen.
Obwohl ich sagen muss, also Federkaffee, Federkaffee in der, da finden ja ganz tolle, wenn der Kaffee sitzen bleibt auf dieser warmen Herdplatte, da finden so chemische Reaktionen statt. Das will man eigentlich gar nicht wissen.
Da reden wir jetzt auch nicht drüber. Ganz furchtbare Sachen, das wollen wir gar nicht wissen. Aber was, was macht denn jetzt eine Espresso-Maschine? Also wenn man jetzt sich jetzt so einen Teil kauft, und wir haben es vorhin schon gesprochen, es scheint ja gerade auch wirklich ein Wahnsinn am Start zu sein mit Kaffeemaschinen. Also hier hat in Berlin gerade dieser neue Saturn aufgemacht. Da ist dann einfach so ein Bereich von der Größe der Computerabteilung, der sich einfach ausschließlich dem Thema Kaffeemaschinen widmet. Und da kann man jetzt so diese Boliden kaufen. Ja, also was weiß ich, man legt sich dann gleich so eine 5000-Kilo-Gadget-Maschine zu, bis hin zu diesen kleinen Plastik-Elektronik-Teilen, die versuchen irgendwie alles ganz klug und schlau und einfach zu machen. Was ist denn die Essenz einer Espresso-Maschine? Also was muss dieses Gerät eigentlich können? Und was macht eine Espresso-Maschine an der Stelle aus? Ist es dann im Wesentlichen der Druck oder was?
Das ist Druck und Temperatur eigentlich. Und eigentlich vergessen wird das Wichtigste, also mindestens genauso wichtig wie die Espresso-Maschine, ist die Mühle. Ach, da geht schon los. Da geht schon los, weil ein guter Kaffee ist frischer Kaffee und frisch gemahlener Kaffee. Sobald Kaffee gemahlen ist, nach vier Minuten fängt er an, trockener zu werden und Aromastoffe zu verlieren. Wenn du vorgemahlenen Kaffee hast, dann wird das nach 15 Minuten immer rapider, also der Aromaverlust. Das heißt, um wirklich guten Espresso machen zu können oder richtig guten Kaffee durch die Espressomaschine, braucht man erstmal eine gute Mühle.
Frisch gemahlenen Kaffee erstmal. Was macht eine gute Mühle aus?
Eine gute Mühle macht aus, dass die gute Mahlscheiben hat und am liebsten für Espresso jetzt konische Mahlscheiben hat. Und dass man die halt auch einstellen kann. Konisch, das sind Mahlscheiben, die sind halt konisch, die sind nicht flach aufeinander, sondern Kegel in Kegel. Das ist deswegen wichtig, damit man verschiedene große Mahlpartikel hat, die dann einen dickeren Extraktionsfluss ergeben. Und die verschiedenen Mahlpartikel dann auch verschiedene Funktionen haben innerhalb dieser Extraktion.
Das heißt, wenn man sich eine gute Mahlmaschine kauft, dann muss man die chronischen Scheiben haben, und dann muss man noch eine Einstellung haben, die dann sozusagen zwei Kegel ineinander gepresst werden.
Am besten ist es dann noch, dass man eine Mühle hat, wo man den Mahlgrad gut einstellen kann, von sehr fein bis etwas gröber. Warum? Weil Kaffee ist hygroskopisch, zieht ganz schnell Feuchtigkeit an, besonders wenn es gemahlen ist. Es gibt aber so etwas wie eine ideale Extraktionsrat, also eine ideale Geschwindigkeit, mit der Kaffee am meisten Aromastoffe dem Wasser abgibt, unter Druck. Und du dann halt das volle Aroma...
Verstehe, das heißt, wenn man ihn zu fein malt, dann ist es auch schon nicht mehr schön.
Dann kommt er zu langsam und dann wird er bitter.
Verstehe, und wenn man ihn zu grob macht, dann kommt das Wasser nicht so richtig rein.
Wenn das grob ist, dann geht das zu schnell. Also dann hat das Wasser keine Zeit, diese Kaffeeöler herauszuziehen, dann kommt es zu schnell und wird säuerlich.
Woran kann man das erkennen, ob man den richtigen Malgrad gemacht hat? Nur am Endergebnis sozusagen. Wenn er zu bitter schmeckt, dann habe ich schon falsch gemahlen.
Kann sein, aber das ist einer von vielen Faktoren, der dann halt falsch gelaufen sein kann.
Verstehe.
Also am besten ist, du beobachtest, dass dein Espresso schaut. Das machen wir auch.
Beim Durchlaufen.
Der sollte halt, je nachdem, ob man jetzt Ausläufe benutzt, links und rechts oder wir arbeiten halt mit offenen Siebträgern, sollte er halt langsam laufen, leicht posieren, von rot-brauner Farbe sein und zwischen 25 bis 30 Sekunden dauern. Bevor er dann weißlich wird, bevor er dann hell wird, blond wird.
Rot-brauner Farbe, also dieser cremige Zustand, in dem es dann irgendwie idealerweise da so rausgedrückt kommt. Wenn man den halt nicht erreicht, dann kann man unter Umständen mit einem Malgrad da noch was verbessern.
Genau, wenn man jetzt...
Mir wird langsam klar, warum Kaffee überhaupt so unterschiedlich schmeckt in so vielen Läden und warum ich auch in der Lage bin, am Kaffee den Laden zu erkennen.
Hey, ich sollte zu wetten, dass gehen.
So weit ist es noch nicht, aber ich meine, das war mir schon... Sie haben mich mal gefragt, liegt es jetzt eigentlich an der Sorte oder liegt das an der Maschine oder was? Ich meine, ich stelle jetzt fest, es liegt einfach an allem.
Es liegt an der Person, die den Kaffee macht.
Genau, an der richtigen Ziege, die das irgendwie vom Baum gezogen hat bis zur richtigen Katze, die da schon das Pre-Processing vorgenommen hat bis hin zum Weihrauch. Aber wir sind ja noch lange nicht fertig. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt den idealen Mahlgrad erwischt. Ich presse das dann da rein. Da ist auch schon die Frage, macht man das dann irgendwie so voll, wie es geht? Muss schon der Kaffee da schon so vorgestampft werden? Oder ist das an der Stelle überhaupt gar nicht relevant?
Also erstmal hast du frisch gemalt und vielleicht ungefähr den richtigen Mahlgrad. Dann hast du deine Maschine, deine Espresse-Maschine. Dann kommt es darauf an, wie viel Druck deine Maschine hat. Neun Bar ist optimal. Ich glaube, kleinere Maschinen haben manchmal mehr. Und was dann wichtig ist, man muss dann schon das Kaffeebett, also Kaffeekuchen, vorbereiten. Was wichtig ist, dass gleichmäßig, also dein Ziel ist es, dass du die Kaffeepartikel, also das Kaffeemehl, so gleichmäßig wie möglich in deinem Siebträger verteilst.
Klar, damit dann das Wasser auch möglichst gleichmäßig da durchzieht.
Genau, das machen wir dann halt. Also wir malen dann rein und wir verteilen das mit dem Finger. Also es heißt to distribute auf Englisch. Also das dann verteilen und dann drücken wir das an mit 14 Kilogramm mit so einem Temper, auf Deutsch Stempel.
14 Kilogramm?
14 Kilogramm. Weil das immer noch genug Druck aufbaut, aber deine Hand, also du kannst halt, wenn du zu Hause einen...
14 Kilogramm jetzt so gefühlt aus der Hand? Oder habt ihr da wirklich so ein 14 Kilogramm Teil, was ihr da so drauflegt?
Also wir hatten, wir haben sehr lange mit einer Waage gearbeitet. Also die dann anzeigt, wie viel Kilogramm du drückst.
Achso, man stellt sozusagen auf die...
Man stellt das Ding auf eine Waage und dann sehe ich dann halt so, ich drücke jetzt mit 14 Kilogramm und jetzt höre ich auf zu drücken. Oder aber es gibt halt Klickertemper. Das sind halt Temper oder Stempel und die geben da schon an, wie viel, also wenn du dann die 14 Kilogramm erreicht hast, dann machen die halt Klick und dann weißt du, ok, jetzt höre ich auf.
Verstehe.
Oder aber du drückst halt so stark wie du drückst, aber drück immer die gleiche Stärke.
Verstehe, also 14 Kilogramm ist sozusagen der gewonnene Wert. Da weiß man, jetzt ist der Kaffee so gut beieinander, dass er irgendwie sich nicht gleich ausspült, wenn da ein bisschen Wasser ankommt. Aber dass er auch nicht so fest ist, dass das Wasser quasi davon abprallt.
Und dann hast du es super vorbereitet, dann hast du es ganz gerade angedrückt, also nicht so schief drücken, weil dann auf der einen Seite, wo der Kaffee stärker zusammengepresst ist, auf der anderen Seite kommt es bitter, auf der anderen Seite kommt es hell raus und sauer. Oder auch bitter.
Ganz falsch hat man es gemacht, wenn man sich das anschaut, und man hat da so ein Einschussloch, und dann sieht man irgendwie, da war irgendwie das ganz stehend.
Oder wenn man so einen Doppelauslauf hat, und die eine Seite kommt schwarz, kommt dann so runtergetropft, und die andere Seite kommt so weiß raus.
Dann war es auf jeden Fall falsch gepresst.
Dann war es falsch gepresst oder falsch verteilt. Und dann hast du halt deine Maschine, was ganz wichtig ist, ist Sauberkeit. Also was wir schon an Kaffeemaschinen gehabt haben, ganz schlimm, also was es nämlich ist, bei Kaffeeöl, die hat vier Öle, und das wird halt ranzig. Und das kann dann wirklich dreckig schmecken. Und deswegen ist Sauberkeit ganz wichtig, dass man die Kaffeemaschine regelmäßig sauber macht. Das ist schon ein unglaubliches Plus an der Espresso-Qualität am Ende. Also wenn die Leute sich eine teure Espresso-Maschine gekauft haben, und die ersten Kaffees waren so lecker, und dann nach einer Woche die Kaffeebonat sich verändert, weil es schmeckt mir nicht mehr so gut.
Meine andere Marke kaufen.
Es liegt nicht daran, sondern deine Maschine ist halt dreckig. Da musst du mal einen Kaffeereiniger dir besorgen, der Kaffeeöle speziell dann herauswaschen kann. Und dann sauber machen.
Was ist das für ein Reiniger? Statt Kaffee füllt man einen Reiniger rein und bläst es damit durch?
Genau. Die Konsumermaschinen haben ja meistens nur einen Tank hinten. So eine Tablette auflösen, einmal komplett durchlaufen lassen und einmal mit dem heißen Wasser, klarem heißem Wasser durchlaufen lassen. Und dann die ersten zwei Shots vielleicht nicht trinken. Da könnte noch ein Rasteife sein. Und erst ab dem dritten. Okay, was ganz wichtig ist, ist die Temperatur bei Kaffee. Der Kaffeegeschmack verändert sich schon ab einem halben Grad Celsius.
Von dem durchlaufenden Wasser.
Und das Problem war, alle Kaffeemaschinen, die gebaut worden sind, vor unserer Maschine, waren eigentlich so konzipiert, dass die eingebaut hatten eine Temperaturdifferenz von 5 Grad. Das ist einfach, wie die gebaut sind. Weil man wusste halt nicht, dass das Kaffee so temperatursensibel ist im Geschmack.
Und eure ist?
Und unsere ist bis auf einen halben Grad genau.
Das heißt, ihr habt da vorne einen Regler und könnt wirklich die Temperatur exakt einstellen?
Ja.
Und welche Temperatur ist da drin? Das ist jetzt schon ein Geschäftsgeheimnis. Jetzt kommen wir in einen kritischen Bereich, oder?
In einem kritischen Bereich, ja.
Sag mal, ein Bereich, in dem sich das so bewegt?
Über 94 Grad.
Okay, über 94 Grad.
Aber die Temperatur, das hängt dann auch damit ab, also wie viel Kaffee man reinmacht, zum Beispiel, oder was das für eine Bohne ist, wie das geröstet worden ist und so weiter. Und dann hast du eine möglichst temperaturstabile Maschine, die auch druckstabil dann den ganzen Kram durchhaut. Und die auch druckstabil ist, genau. Und dann lockst du das ein, ziehst deinen Espresso-Short und dann solltest du eigentlich einen perfekten Espresso haben. Und es ist...
Und es ist was?
Und es verändert sich halt ständig. Also du hast jetzt deine... Also was das jetzt zum Beispiel im Kaffeebereich ist, dadurch, dass Kaffee eben hygroskopisch ist, dann kommt dann halt eine Gruppe von Leuten rein und dann verändert sich halt dieser ideale Malgrad und dann muss man das halt umstellen und dann wieder...
Das heißt, ihr seid ja wirklich die ganze Zeit irgendwie am Regeln, als würde man da gerade Flugzeug fliegen? Ah ja, der Filterkaffee.
Filterkaffee ist ja wieder im Kommen.
Vielleicht noch mal kurz zum Thema, also wenn man jetzt nicht selber eine Kaffeemaschine kauft, also so eine Expressmaschine kaufen will, kannst du da irgendwie mal so grob sagen, worauf man da jetzt achten soll, oder ist das irgendwie alles vergebende Liebesmühungen, man muss es letzten Endes ausprobieren, bevor man weiß. Ich meine, gibt es irgendwie, keine Ahnung, gibt es irgendwie so Marken, bei denen man nichts falsch machen kann, wie wir jetzt hier nicht in so eine Empfindungs-Show abgleiten oder...
Ja, aber wir empfehlen immer die Ranchi-Liu Silvia. Das hatten wir auch ausprobiert. Die wird halt auch von... Erstens hat die so eine Art Fan-Club. Die hat so einen Fan-Club, also da können sich Leute austauschen. Und dann, was mit diesen kleinen Maschinen ist, was tricky ist, ist ja deren Aufheizkurve. Man muss ja irgendwie wissen, also wann, wenn ich jetzt Milch davor geschäumt habe, wann ist dann die Temperatur wieder hoch genug, dass die hoch genug ist, um den Kaffee zu machen? Und wie lange, also so. Und die Maschine ist für eine Consumer-Maschine relativ temperaturstabil und man kann die auch noch pimpen. Also man kann dann auch so einen... Den Temperaturstabilisator da noch rein basteln.
Spoiler sozusagen.
Ja, machen auch viele Leute. Und die hat halt auch Siebträger, die ein bisschen größer sind. Und wir haben selbst da beim Kunden dann mal unseren Kaffee gemacht. Es ist möglich, aber es ist viel Arbeit und man braucht sehr viel Dedication. Also, das ist wirklich... Also, guten Espresso zu Hause zu machen, ist was für tüftler. Wenn man keine professionelle Espresso-Maschine hat.
Okay, aber man kann sich auch im Internet schlau machen, zum Beispiel, in diesen Foren. Jetzt gibt es noch so ein anderes Mysterium. Wenn man heute hier in Berlin in so einem halbwegs... Wie soll ich sagen? Ich fange mal anders an. Es gibt eine unglaubliche Vielfalt an Bezeichnungen für Kaffee-Endprodukte. Also, man will halt irgendwie Kaffee trinken. Die Frage ist, was trinkt man? Jetzt, wenn es in Berlin so ist, wirst du kennen, die Standardeinheit hier heißt irgendwie Milchkaffee. Das hat wahrscheinlich irgendwie außerhalb von Berlin...
Kennst du den Latte Macchiato Song von den Helmys? Ich muss dich mal promoten, die Helmys. Die machen ein Puppentheater und kommen vom Helmholtzplatz und die haben einen ganz tollen Song über die Mütter mit dem Latte Macchiato. Also, sehr zu empfehlen, also nur so mal zwischendurch.
Das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen, der Latte Macchiato. Aber, also, los geht's ja sozusagen mit Milchkaffee. Milchkaffee ist ja wirklich ein extrem dehnbarer Begriff. Aber was ist jetzt deine Vorstellung davon, was das in Berlin tatsächlich ist? Oder anders gefragt, wie verhalten sich jetzt diese Sachen? Cappuccino, Espresso, Milchkaffee, was gibt es noch? Kaffee Latte lese ich. Es gibt offensichtlich sehr unterschiedliche Auffassungen darüber, was das ist. Gibt es da irgendwas, worauf man sich geeinigt hat?
Oder ist das alles... Wir halten uns ein bisschen an Italiener.
Ja, das ist gut.
Die haben ja die Espresso-Maschine auch erfunden.
Genau.
Also bei uns ist ein Espresso... ein Espresso...
Das ist erstmal der reine Schott.
Das ist der reine Schott. Da gibt es natürlich verschiedene Auffassungen. Unsere Interpretation vom Espresso ist kürzerer Schott mehr Kaffee. Deswegen also stärker und aromatischer und dicker. Dann haben wir den Cappuccino.
Gibt es da nicht eine Definition einer Menge für so ein Espresso? Ist ja aber relativ wenig.
Also die italienische Definition ist 6 bis 8 Gramm. Standard ist 7 Gramm. Ist allerdings vom Mundgefühl eher dünner, als jetzt den Espresso, den wir machen. Um nochmal den Bogen zu schlagen, wenn der Kaffeeshot am Ende ein bisschen blond wird, nachdem er dann extrahiert, also es fließt dick rot-braun heraus, und dann wird er, wenn er ausextrahiert ist, wenn er sozusagen erschöpft ist, kommt dann noch so ein bisschen helleres Kaffee-Wasser heraus. Und das macht fast ein Drittel aus bei dem italienischen Espresso-Shot mit 7 Gramm, weil der einfach nicht genug Material hat. Also 7 Gramm hat halt nur so und so viel. Deswegen trinken auch viele Italiener Restretto, weil der kürzer ist.
Restretto.
Restretto, dann hat man halt diesen Teil, der eigentlich schon ausextrahiert ist und nur noch so Flüssigkeit dazu gibt und dann halt das dünner macht, den hat man dann nicht mehr dabei.
Das ist relativ unumstritten. Man kriegt da eigentlich schon in der Regel immer dasselbe, wenn es nicht gerade Restretto ist.
Espresso Macchiato ist Milchschaum draufgelöffelt. Auf den Espresso.
Milchschaum draufgelöffelt.
Also bei uns sind das wirklich dann zwei Lagen. Espresso und der Schaum. Gemarkt, markiert heißt das auf Italienisch. Also ein Espresso markiert mit Milch. So, im Gegensatz zum Latte Macchiato, das ist Milch markiert mit ein bisschen Kaffee.
Ah, da dreht man sozusagen um.
Ja, und das ist eigentlich ein Kindergetränk in Italien. Das ist für die Kinder, die auch gerne Kaffee trinken müssen, aber noch nicht dürfen.
Ah, da ist nicht so viel Kaffee drin, also kriegen sie im Wesentlichen heiße Milch, aber es ist ein bisschen braun. Und das finden jetzt gerade alle so geil. Ich geh jetzt nochmal auf den Helmholzplatz und trinke meinen Latte Macchiato.
Das ist die Geschichte von Latte Macchiato.
Verstehe, man markiert die Milch mit etwas Kaffee.
Ja, mit etwas Kaffee.
Okay, das ist für Schwangere sehr geeignet, so für kleine Kinder, aber an sich hat es mit Kaffee nicht mehr so viel zu tun.
Nicht wirklich, es ist halt ein Hauch Kaffee. Und dann meistens ist das auch so, dass die Latte Macchiato, die sehr groß sind, das heißt, man kriegt eigentlich kalten Kaffee. Also der wird vorher in irgendwas anderes hinein extrahiert, steht dann eine Weile rum. Und der ist dann eigentlich schon kalt und wird dann halt so... Es geht auch nur mit kalten, abgestandenem Kaffee, dass man dieses Layering hinkriegt.
Ah, das ist der Effekt, dass man da so einen Kaffee unten hat und die Milch oben.
Ja, genau, dass man da so verschiedene Ebenen hat und so. Das ist auch nur mit kalten Kaffee möglich, nicht mit frischen.
Ich sehe schon. Latte Macchiato hat so in der Kaffee-Kultur nicht so einen hohen Stand.
Also wenn jemand sagt, ich hätte gerne Latte Macchiato mit Macadamia Nuss, dann ein bisschen zieht sich da was zusammen. Habt ihr Haselnuss, Vanille?
Ist das... passiert das wirklich?
Ist auch nicht so schlimm. Ich also... Ja doch, eigentlich ist es schlimm. Ich vertrag das nicht so gut. Also einmal am Tag kann ich es vertragen, aber mehr nicht. Gut. Dann haben wir den Cappuccino, ein Drittel Espresso, ein Drittel warme Milch, ein Drittel Schaum.
Ein Drittel Espresso bzw. ein vollständiger Shot und dann halt nochmal in der Menge des Shots...
Warme Milch.
Und dann Schaum.
Und dann Schaum. Das ist Cappuccino.
Das ist ein Cappuccino.
Und was ist deine Theorie, wo der Name herkommt?
Das ist von den Cappuccinamönchen. Früher wurde der so gemacht, dass du halt... Außen ist es halt braun und oben ist es halt weiß, rund. Und die hatten ja diese Cappuccinamönche, die haben ja hier so eine Platte oben, ne? Und dann wächst der so und ist hart drum herum. Wer kommt der Begriff Cappuccino? Dann haben wir den Café Latte. Das ist ein Espresso-Short in der Tasse. Und dann kommt man mit Milch dazu. Den bieten wir auch an.
Das ist also eigentlich genauso wie Cappuccino, bloß ohne den Milchschaum?
Ähm, weniger Milchschaum und mehr Milch. Dann bieten wir zum Beispiel noch an den Flat White. Das wäre dann, also das haben die Neuseeländer in Australien erfunden, das wäre eigentlich ein, also der klassische italienische Cappuccino wird auch gemacht mit 7 Gramm Kaffee pro Cappuccino. Die traditionelle Erklärung von Flat White wäre einen doppelten Shot, also 14 Gramm in eine Cappuccino-Tasse mit dünnerem Milch-Schaum, also wie Kaffee Latte dann, aber dann konzentrierter, ist also von der Stärke her zwischen Cappuccino und Kaffee Latte.
Also der Name ist ein bisschen irreführend, weil er irgendwie so einen in Richtung Milch bringt, aber eigentlich ist da mehr Kaffee drin.
Eigentlich ist da mehr Kaffee drin, aber da, also wir bei uns machen überall ganz viel Kaffee rein, deswegen.
So und jetzt das Mysterium. Was ist der Berliner Milchkaffee?
Also ich habe gehört, ich habe gerüchteweise gehört, es wäre Filterkaffee mit warmem Milch oben drauf und ein bisschen Schaum später noch drauf.
Aber das stimmt ja eigentlich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich meine, es gibt hier einfach die Einheit Milchkaffee in Berlin. Man geht hier irgendwo hin und dann kommt das aber aus der Espressomaschine. Also eigentlich stimmt es nicht mit Filterkaffee. Aber ihr habt es sozusagen nicht im Angebot.
Es gibt keinen Milchkaffee, nein. Also wenn jemand bei uns Latte Macchiato oder Milchkaffee bestellt, kriegt er immer einen Kaffeelatte.
Verstehe. Kaffeelatte.
Es gibt ja noch Café au Lait. Gibt es ja auch noch.
Das ist Französisch.
Das ist Französisch, aber die sind nicht gut im Kaffeekochen.
Aber was ist der Café au Lait?
Aber ich glaube, das ist dieser Milchkaffee. Der Peterkaffee. Und da war Milch und ein bisschen Milchschau drauf.
Na gut, aber jetzt haben wir endlich mal Klarheit. Das war wirklich bitter nötig.
Americano?
Stimmt, sowas gibt es auch noch.
Also normaler schwarzer Kaffee durch die Espressomaschine gibt es nicht. Also bei uns wäre das dann heißes Wasser mit einem Espressoschott um drauf. Das nennt sich Americano.
Das heißt verdünnter Espresso. Aber heißes Wasser, damit es nicht leidet.
Ja, aber auch nicht zu heiß, sonst wird es bitter.
Die richtige Gradzahl ist hier wieder entscheidend. Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, als ich mal Kaffee bei euch bezogen habe, wurde er auch hübsch verziert. Seid ihr denn auch so im Latte-Art ganz gut unterwegs? Ich beziehe mich jetzt auf die Verhübschung des Endprodukts, insbesondere der Cappuccino. Wenn er schon mal drauf ist, wird er dann noch mit Kakaopulver, oder was macht man eigentlich normalerweise drauf? Ist das Kakaopulver?
Beim Kaffee Latte machen wir Kakaopulver, beim Cappuccino nicht. Das ist wirklich nur die Crema, die diesen Kontrast bringt.
Crema im Sinne von der Kaffee?
Ja, der Kaffee. Also die erste so...
Aber du bist ja bestimmt vertraut mit diesem Begriff Latteart.
Ja, wir legen großen Wert auf Latteart.
Also wir reden jetzt von dieser Verzierung, der Haube des eigentlich schon fertigen Kaffeeprodukts. Und dann geht man da mit was rein?
Mit einem Holz? Nein, gar nicht. Also wir gehen überhaupt nicht mit irgendwelchen Stäbchen rein. Also der Fachbegriff für Stäbchen Latteart ist Etching. Ja, das machen wir nicht, weil wir finden... Wir haben da nicht zu suchen ein Getränk vom Kunden. Wir packen auch kein Sirup drüber und machen da so Etching. Das machen wir nicht, aber wir machen Latteart, freigeschenkte Latteart und das ist daher möglich, weil Kaffee und Milch unterschiedliche Dichten haben. Und das ist dann so wie Skateboardfahren lernen oder so. Man muss ganz viel üben. Bis man dann halt die Bewegung... Weißt du, wie diese Bewegung, wenn du deinen Bauch reiben sollst in eine Richtung und dann über deinen Kopf diese Kreisbewegungen machen. Also sowas... also diese Schwierigkeitsgrad ist diese Latteart. Man muss halt... Die Milch muss in einer perfekten Konsistenz sein, in einer Mikroblasenkonsistenz, eingeführt von Herrn Schoma. Und dann musst du das mit einer gewissen Geschwindigkeit gießen. Man muss halt schnell genug sein, bevor sich die Milch trennt. Also die Milch will immer sich vom Schaum trennen. Und dann musst du halt durch deine Bewegung, also der Milchstrahl bleibt immer gleich, die Geschwindigkeit. Und durch deine Handbewegungen baust du halt Druck auf, damit du dann mit dem Milchschaum in der Crema zeichnen kannst. Verstehe. Aber das muss man sehen.
Ich kann mir das jetzt schon live ganz gut vorstellen. Das ist nachvollziehbar. Vor allem das mit dem Bauch streicheln und über den Kopf kreisen und so. Das ist auch so ein bisschen diese Fähigkeit, die man beim Didgeridoo spielen entwickeln muss, dass man gleichzeitig bläst und atmet.
Ja, habe ich nie gemeistert, aber Latte Art, das geht.
Sieht auf jeden Fall sehr hübsch aus. Da gibt es ja richtig Meisterschaften.
Da gibt es richtig Meisterschaften, ja. Ich glaube, dass aber auch Edging erlaubt. Ich glaube, da ist auch so ein Koreaner, der da ganz gut ist.
Das Internet ist voll davon, aber bei YouTube, da kann man sich...
Das ist auch echt spaßig für Leute, zu Hause sowas zu üben.
Aber du sagtest ja, der Filter-Café ist wieder am Kommen, oder ist das jetzt nur deine persönliche Meinung?
Das ist wieder am Kommen. Und meine persönliche Meinung, beides.
Das hast du ja schon erwähnt, Milita ist eine deutsche Erfindung. Genau, eine deutsche Erfindung, das war, wie war das noch gleich? Die Frau hieß Milita.
Die Frau hieß Milita, ja. Die hat das aus Löschpapier gemacht.
Weil bis dahin, wie das ja auch in Südländern sehr verbreitet ist, da kriegt man ja, also dieser, ich glaube, türkischer Café, ist so die gängigste Bezeichnung dafür, da hat man dann quasi den Kaffee noch in der Tasse als Bodensatz. Das kriegt man irgendwie überall. Das kriegt man da so in der Türkei so, ich weiß nicht, Griechenland, glaube ich, auch noch ein bisschen verbreitet. So, und das war sozusagen ihr Zuwider. Oder passte ihr nicht?
Das passte ihr nicht. Nee, die wollte das halt nicht im Mund haben.
Und dann hat sie irgendwie Löschpapier genommen, hat gesagt, das geht ja auch super.
Ja, und hat dann noch diesen Trichter entwickelt und dann gebaut und dann war das wieder total der Hit. Das war dann total der Hit.
Und deswegen trinken die Deutschen Filter-Café.
Ja, wer dann die Maschine dazu gebaut hat, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, wer das verbrauchen hat.
Aber die Italiener fanden das auf jeden Fall nicht toll. Kaffee-Tetesco.
Aber die amerikanischen Kaffee mögen die ja auch nicht.
Aber für dich ist das jetzt so keine Verletzung des Puritanismus, dass man jetzt da irgendwie noch so ein bisschen...
Nee, aber die Idee von handgefiltertem Filterkaffee ist eigentlich gut. Also frischen Kaffee, damals hat man ja auch noch die Kaffeemühle gehabt. Da wurde auch öfter frischer geröstet. Das ganze Hightech-Verpackungszeug hatte man ja nicht. Da gab es viel mehr Röstereien, hat man sich dann Kaffee gekauft in Kaffeetüte und dann hatte man seine schöne Handmühle.
Die Oma war im Räuberhorzenplatz.
Ach so, ich kenne die.
Ja, der wurde in die Kaffemühle gestohlen. Das war das große Hallo in der Boch.
Das habe ich leider nicht gelesen.
Das muss man machen. Ist dein Thema, wie er geht, alles um die Kaffemühle.
Also da ist auch eine deutsche Firma marktführend immer noch an den Handmühlen. Die ist Tassenhausen.
Ach, die gibt es noch?
Er hat wieder eine Revive. Ich sage doch auch, was zum Kommen.
Dann sagen wir gleich mal, wie diese Firma ist.
Tassenhausen.
Tassenhausen baut nur die original Handmühlen sozusagen. Genau.
Und die kann man auch verstellen, formal geradeher.
Okay, chronische Mahlscheiben.
Und dann macht man auch gleichzeitig Sport. Das ist ganz wunderbar.
Machst du das auch so? Ich meine, hast du?
Nein, ich echt nie. Wir haben eine elektrische.
Du bist dann doch faul.
Wir haben eine elektrische.
Aber wer sozusagen nicht genug kriegen kann von der Handarbeit, der nimmt sich dann irgendwie so eine Handarbeit.
Ja, ich glaube, für Filter meint der jetzt Mitarbeiter von uns, das geht dann auch. Das ist so grob.
Ist das also auch so ein Holzteil dann auch?
Es gibt verschiedene Ausführungen. Es gibt so die, welche für Single-Männer, glaube ich, so mit so Stahl und so. Es gibt auch die alte mit Holz. Es gibt auch die Reisehandmühle, die hat dann so einen arabischen Stil.
Eine Reise-Kaffeehandmühle. Für so, wenn man mal unterwegs ist im ICE oder so, wenn man Kaffee haben will.
Das ist super.
Ja, das ist großartig.
Und vor allen Dingen, man verbraucht auch keine. Also es ist total energiesparend.
Also ich muss zugeben, ich hab so eine elektrische Mühle, wo ich auch überhaupt nichts einstellen kann. Da sind nur so fliegende Scheiben irgendwie in der Mitte so ein kleiner Propeller.
Ja, das geht eigentlich dann nur für die Bodumkanne. Alles andere, die zerschreddert die eben.
Verstehe, ich sehe schon, ich muss aufrüsten. Das wird mir ganz teuer.
Aber Handgefähr das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Das Schlimme sind ja nur eigentlich diese Kaffeemaschinen, die dann halt ewig auf dieser Herdplatte sitzen. Und dann diese chemischen Prozesse stattfinden, über die wir ja nicht reden wollten.
Du hast vorhin schon mal erwähnt, vor dem Gespräch hast du erwähnt, dass es irgendwie so drei Wellen des Kaffeekonsums sich abzeichnen, jetzt in Deutschland oder generell?
Generell, weltweit oder vielleicht auf westliche Welt, wo jetzt immer mehr in den Erzeugerländern auch Kaffee gemacht wird, auch Espresso, das ist jetzt da auch am Kommen. Und zwar sagt man, die erste Welle, das ist sozusagen der Filter-Kaffee, also der Kaffee der industriellen Revolution.
Also das erste Mal, dass Kaffee überhaupt so in Massen verfügbar war. Ist Frau Melitta schon zu beigetragen oder kam das noch vorher? Also erst gab es irgendwie Kaffee, dann haben sie alle getrunken, und dann wollten sie irgendwann nicht mehr das Kaffeemel im Maul haben, und dann kam Frau Melitta und dann wurde alles ganz toll.
Und dann konnte man das auch so in Dosen packen, also dann kamen auch diese ganzen Verpackungen, und dann konnte man das mehr verbreiten, und man konnte auch den Kaffee besser transportieren, man hatte dann größere Schiffe und Container, und dann hatte man auch glaube ich zwei Kriege, da hat man das ja auch ziemlich stark genutzt, die Amis auch, die haben das auch sehr verbreitet dann.
Sozusagen als Doping, als Soldatendoping oder wie?
Ja, also Kaffee als Droh ist ja immer aktuell. Also das war damals dann auch wichtig, um wach zu bleiben. Das nennte man dann A Cup of Joe oder so. Das war die erste Welle, dann die zweite Welle. Also innerhalb unserer Kaffeeszene nennen wir das dann halt die Specialty-Koffeeszene, das ist dann halt mit Starbucks. Also diese, das plötzlich an jeder Ecke Espresso-Bars sind. Coffee-Shops, dieses Kaffee als Lebensgefühl, als dritter Ort.
Erstaunen Sie sich eigentlich nicht, wodurch wurde das ausgelöst? Ich meine, da hat ja Starbucks nicht unbedingt den Trend gesetzt oder doch?
Also ich glaube doch, dass Starbucks einen ganz großen Einfluss drauf hatte, weil er ja als erster so, also für den amerikanischen Markt, ich weiß das jetzt, der war ja eigentlich nicht so aktiv, wie das hier in Deutschland, also für den amerikanischen Markt sagt man, dass er Orte geschaffen hat, wo sich junge Leute treffen konnten, außerhalb von zu Hause oder Schule. Und außerhalb von McDonalds. Und dass man dort halt gemütlich sitzen konnte, einen sozialen Raum hat und dann... Ja, so Kaffee mit Macadamia Nut trinken konnte und dann da halt abhängen konnte.
Also schon fast mehr eigentlich so die soziale Komponente, dass der Kaffee jetzt sozusagen als Genussmittel mehr so ein Aufhänger war, aber es eigentlich geschaffen wurde...
Ja, das ging dann so...
So eine neue Kaffee-Kultur, eine soziale Kaffee-Kultur, die sich...
Ja, die ganz eng mit Espresso, also Espresso-Maschinen und Kaffee aus Espresso-Maschinen zusammenhängt.
Das hat ja auch so was, wie soll ich sagen, meditative, dieses Gurgel, diese Maschinen, das Gezische. Mich macht das immer ganz high. Also ich hab eigentlich auch im Wesentlichen meine Jugend so sehr produktiv in Cafés verbracht. Produktiv daher, weil ich irgendwie in solchen Umgebungen eigentlich viel besser arbeiten konnte als zu Hause. Weil mir dieses Gebrabbel und wahrscheinlich auch das Geblubber der Kaffeemaschinen in irgendeiner Form was gegeben hat. Kann ich jetzt gar nicht näher bezeichnen, aber war einfach mal so.
Also was ich mag an Koffeeshops oder Cafés, man ist halt allein, aber trotzdem nicht allein. Und man ist leicht angeregt und...
Vielleicht passt das einfach zu diesem Trend in unserer Gesellschaft, so dieses individuelle ein bisschen hervorzukehren, so dieser persönliche Genuss, so dieses irgendwie sich selbst zelebrieren, andererseits aber auch nicht komplett nur alleine rumzuhängen und dann trotzdem noch diese Simulation des Gemeinsamen zu haben. Das könnte vielleicht eine mögliche Erklärung sein. Aber das war die zweite Welle. Also es kamen halt einfach Läden, ein kommerzieller Erfolg, eigene Kaffee-Kultur, das Café auch wieder sozusagen als wiedergeborener Treffpunkt. Aber das gab es ja in manchen Ländern auch schon vorher. Also wenn man jetzt in Österreich, da wo die türkischen Kaffeesäcke aufgeschlagen sind, diese Caféhaus-Kultur, die viel gerühmte, was ist da dran? Ich meine, wer traf sich da? Das war ja dann sozusagen noch eine Welle, die jetzt so mit der Verbreitung von Milliliterfilter-Café nichts zu tun hat, sondern wo es ja auch schon dieser Ort war und wo das ja auch immer so der Ort war, wo sich die Christen viel getroffen haben.
Deswegen ist das auch etwas Besonderes, das Wiener Caféhaus, für sich.
Die haben ja auch noch mal so ihre eigenen Worte.
Die Wiener Melange zum Beispiel. Aber ich denke, als globales Phänomen ist das wirklich in diesen Wänden zu beschreiben, dass die Wiener dann schon so glücklich waren, das schon seit dem 17. und 18. Jahrhundert zu haben.
Das heißt, die Österreicher haben sich nicht nur gewundert, warum das so lang gedauert hat. Aber bei euch gibt es ja auch gar keinen... Bei euch gibt es ja irgendwie nicht immer ein Wasser dazu. Gibt es bei Starbucks immer ein Wasser zum Kaffee? Ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube nicht, ne?
Es ist schon eine Weile her, dass ich da war, muss ich sagen.
Also letztes Mal, als ich... ja dann, ich ändere mich. Ja, ich muss sagen, mir schmeckt dieser Kaffee sogar. Aber das kann auch daran liegen, dass ich hier eigentlich nie bei Starbucks abhänge. Hätten sie freies Internet, hätte das sicherlich anders rausgesehen. Aber das haben sie ja nicht durchringen können. Aber ich war jetzt irgendwie in Kanada. Und Kanada ist einfach... also Toronto... Wie soll ich sagen? Es war sehr schwierig, Orte zu finden, wo man jetzt wirklich immer so...
In Kanada?
Ja, wo man wieder aufschlägt.
Die haben ganz gute Kurven.
Was haben die da?
Das nächste Mal, wenn du gehst, sag mal Bescheid.
Ja, ich war dann immer sehr im Zentrum gefangen und so weiter. Weil die Auswahl war jetzt nicht so groß. Und da war halt Starbucks nicht unbedingt die schlechteste Wahl. Also da gab es schlechtere Wahlen. Es gab da definitiv, wie hieß denn auch dieser andere bekloppte Laden, wo sie alle hingelangen sind. Es gab dann irgendwas Kanadisches, Starbucks-ähnliches. Da war der Kaffee wirklich schlecht. Und im Vergleich dazu kam Starbucks noch gut weg. Aber es gab kein Wasser dazu. Und da sind ja die Österreicher dann doch sehr hinterher, dass man mit seiner Melange dann eben auch noch so dieses kleine Stückchen Wasser dazu bekommt. Mit diesem bitteren Geschmack, damit er rauszukriegen. Ich finde den übrigens auch schön bitter, diese Melange. So ein bisschen bitter, oder? Dann bilde ich mir das jetzt nun gerade ein.
Ich hab noch nicht so ehlenvolle Laute da.
Ich merke das schon. Und in Italien, gibt es da auch so was Vergleichbares? Also sowas wie Caféhäuser in dem Sinne eigentlich nicht?
Die haben ja diese Bar und das ist immer so ein bisschen so bistromäßig und dann haben sie eben diese Espressomaschine dastehen.
Das ist mehr Teil der Restaurantkultur geworden, oder?
Ich überleg, wir waren ja da, das war immer so Espresso und Sandwiches, glaube ich. Oder Tankstellen und Espresso, das gab es auch noch.
Okay, wir äußern uns zu etwas, das wir uns vielleicht besser nicht äußern sollten, weil wir keine Ahnung haben. Tatsache ist, die zweite Welle hat stattgefunden und man kann es hier sehen. Und jetzt kommt die dritte Welle.
Und die dritte Welle, wie ich schon erzählt habe, das waren halt Leute, die haben sich übers Internet ausgetauscht, über neue Erkenntnis über Kaffee, also Kaffee-Nerds eigentlich. Und es ging dann parallel damit auch, dass Coffee-Shops entstanden sind, die sich dem total verpflichtet haben, und Kaffee eigentlich als kulinarisches Erlebnis zu zelebrieren und die Zubereitung wirklich ernst zu nehmen, also wie ein Koch zum Beispiel sein Essen macht und eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit und Konzentration dafür hat. Also das fängt schon damit an, okay, dass man nicht irgendwelche Studenten, die man fünf Minuten einweist und drückt man den Knopf und die dann gar nicht gucken, was da eigentlich passiert und dann in, weiß ich nicht, 30 Kaffee in einer Sekunde rauskloppen hat, sondern dass man sich anguckt, okay, was habe ich da für ein Produkt? Woher kommt das? Wie wurde das geröstet? Wie bereite ich das jetzt optimal zu? Und das ging halt auch noch einher mit technischen Verbesserungen. Wie eben diese Erspassmaschinen, die wir haben, oder auch die Mühlen haben sich jetzt weiterentwickelt. Die werden jetzt alle gekühlt. Weil die Mahlscheiben, wenn man gesehen hat, die Mahlscheiben werden zu heiß, dann verbrennt der Kaffee da drin wieder auch.
Gekühlte Mahlscheiben?
Gekühlte Mahlscheiben. Also das hört sich jetzt so Hightech an, aber eigentlich ist es so ein Fan, der da so bläst.
Ja, aber da muss man auch drauf kommen, auf die Idee.
Wir hatten auch die erste fan-gekühlte Mühle.
Ist das alles noch nachweisbar im Endprodukt? Es klingt bisweilen schon so ein bisschen wie goldene Audio-Kabel. So in diesem Hi-Fi-Bereich, wo man es nochmal in so Weihwassertums, bevor man eine CD anwirft.
Doch, ja. Auf jeden Fall.
Aber es ist so ein bisschen die Mischung. Irgendwas kommt wirklich in den Kaffee an, aber das kann vielleicht nur der Experte nachweisen. Oder es ist einfach nur das Karma, was stimmen muss.
Nein, wir machen jetzt doch keine Hexentanz oder so holistisch. Heute geht es nicht Leute, der Mund steht schlecht, wir können jetzt keinen Kaffee machen. Die Milch dreht sich, die Milchmoleküle drehen sich heute nach links.
Achso, welche Milch nehmt ihr denn? Das ist ja auch noch so ein Mysterium.
Wir nehmen eine ganz fette Milch.
Ihr nehmt fette Milch?
Wir nehmen richtig dicke fette Milch.
Es gibt so ein Mythos, dass die fettärmere Milch angeblich besser schäumen soll. Aber das habe ich noch nie bestätigen können.
Nein, die schäumt nicht besser, was die macht. Sie produziert trockeneren Schaum. Deswegen wird die schneller, stärkt die so nach oben. Aber die Struktur ist nicht cremig, sondern ist eher trockener Bauschaum. Und dieser fette Milch überträgt durch die ganzen Fettmönche erstmal den Geschmack besser, verbindet sich besser mit dem Kaffee. Und die kann man halt cremiger von der Textur her machen.
Das heißt, ihr nehmt so 3,8% Milch, diese Bauernmilch sozusagen. Also was ja eigentlich schon der natürliche Fettgehalt ist, glaube ich, der Milch, oder?
Da bin ich jetzt überfragt, welches vier, ich weiß nicht.
Okay, aber auf jeden Fall, ständige Milch.
Also ziemlich fette Milch von guter Qualität.
Und wie schäumt man am besten auf?
Also die Kunst des Aufschäums ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Man braucht eine Schaumdüse. Die Milch sollte so kalt wie möglich sein, weil dann schäumt sie am besten. Also die Milch sollte dann auch kühl sein. Dann sollte man die Schaumdüse ein bisschen unter die Milchoberfläche stecken und versuchen, wenn man jetzt den Druck aufbaut, diesen Dampfdruck, dass man ein leichtes Zwischenhört. Nein, nein, nein, das ist falsch. Nein, das ist falsch.
Zwischen muss es.
Das muss so...... machen. Nein, das ist auch nicht. Das ist auch nicht. Also wirklich, ohne... Man muss sich wirklich auf das Geräusch konzentrieren. Also beim Espresso-Shot ist das visuell. Da muss man gucken, wie der aussieht und beim Andrücken halt, was man fühlt. Und beim Milchschrein muss man hören, was passiert jetzt hier. Also man hat die Hand am Milchkennchen und fügt jetzt ein bisschen Luft hinzu. Das ist dieses... ohne aber die Oberfläche zu brechen. Die Oberfläche brechen würde dann...... sein, ne? Eine große Blase. Genau. Also es muss nur so ganz bisschen unter der Milchoberfläche...... und man kreiert gleichzeitig einen Wirbel und kann also diese Luft hinzufügen, also diesen Schaum aufbauen, bis die Milch handwarm ist. Danach fügt man nur noch Blasen hinzu. Also nachdem die handwarm ist, dann nur noch zum Erhitzen die Schaumdüse ein bisschen tiefer in die Milch tun und nur noch verwirbeln.
Dass man dann auch so die Hitze erzeugt.
Genau, dass man noch die Hitze erzeugt. Die wird dann auch noch ein bisschen dicker, aber halt nicht mehr so massiv.
Der Schaum ist dann sozusagen schon durch. Erst kommt der Schaum, dann gibt man den Milch, den Rest, und dann kommt das irgendwie rein.
Ja, und dann macht man die warme Weißwanne, die fertig ist, wenn man sie nicht mehr anfassen kann. Das funktioniert immer. Dann ist es heiß genug. Und dann ist der Milchschaum fertig.
Was ist denn dein Lieblings...
Ah ja, zu dem Quietschen nochmal zu kommen, was das ist. Das ist, wenn du zu wenig Luft hinzugefügt hast und das am Boden ist von der Milchkanne und die Milch zu heiß ist, dann quietscht das ganz furchtbar. Also wenn die Schaumdüse zu weit unten ist.
Wie trinkst du denn deinen Kaffee am liebsten?
Am liebsten mag ich den Flat White. Ein bisschen weniger Milch, manchmal mit zwei Shots. Also es wäre ein vierfacher Shot in normalem Kaffee. Bei uns ist es dann nur ein doppelter Shot.
Also magst du ihn kräftig?
Mag ich ihn kräftig, ja. Allerdings bin ich auch total auf Filterkaffee.
Filterkaffee.
Handgefilterter Kaffee.
Du hast vorhin irgendwie irgendwas erwähnt, als du bei mir in der Küche einen Dekanter gesehen hast. Was war das? Dass jetzt irgendwie auch ein Dekanter zum Einsatz kommt, um irgendwie Kaffee zu machen?
Nein.
Oder war das nur der Bezug auf den Wein?
Das war der Bezug auf den Wein, dass der Weihnachtsprodukt ist, der fertig, sobald er in der Flasche ist. Also das Einzige, was man noch falsch machen kann, ist, den zu lange am Dekanter zu lassen oder den Dekanter aus der Spülmaschine zu heiß. Also man kann da nicht so viel falsch machen. Das Produkt ist fertig, man gießt das ein. Bei Kaffee ist die Zubereitung, kann auch so viel verändern an der Qualität des Kaffees. Du kannst die Supermüllung...
Aber der Dekanter hat auch genau die Aufgabe, dass wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel den Rotwein irgendwie einfüllt, dass man ihn in diesem Dekanter mit einer möglichst großen Oberfläche noch eine Weile stehen lässt, damit er sich noch so ein bisschen mit dem Sauerstoff binden kann, bevor man ihn dann wirklich dekutiert. Das ist ja Sinn und Zweck dieses Dekanters. Aber der Kaffee, ich meine, wenn der erstmal drin ist, dann brauchen wir ihn eigentlich nur noch wegkauen. Oder ändert er sich dann?
Ja, aber erstmal muss er zubereitet werden. Und das ist natürlich dann wieder...
Das haben wir ja nun in epischer Breite dargestellt.
Ja, deswegen machen wir jetzt... Eine tolle Reise. Es wird schwierig mit Kaffee, weil das ist so unglaublich komplex.
So ist die Welt. Haben wir denn noch irgendwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen?
Außer, dass Filter-Kaffee in der neuen Trend wird?
Ich hab dich ganz gut leer gepresst.
Ja, ich bin jetzt ausextrahiert.
Du bist extrahiert, wie ein feiner Milchschirm. Yumi Super, das war eine tolle Reise in die Kaffee-Welt und ich denke, der geneigte Nerd wird jetzt noch zwei- und dreimal darüber nachdenken, wie er bisher seinen Kaffee gemacht hat und wie er es vielleicht künftig macht.
Nichts ist so, wie es scheint.
Genau, das kompliziert, als man denkt. Genau, wer in Berlin ist, ist eingeladen, mal bei euch herumzuschauen und sich das mal live anzuschauen, wie wirklich detailliert Kaffeeproduktion auch sein kann. Ja, und dann bleibt mir jetzt eigentlich nichts mehr weiter, als mich zu bedanken für die Ausführung. Das war ganz toll und bei den Hörern bedanke ich mich auch. Wieder mal fürs Zuhören hier bei Chaosradio Express. Wie immer, Kommentare gerne gesehen im Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de, zu dieser wie auch zu allen anderen Sendungen. Ich freue mich auch immer mal wieder, wenn ihr die Sendung in eurem Blog erwähnt oder vielleicht auch auf einzelne Sendungen hinweist, wenn es euch denn hier gefallen hat mit dem Thema Chaosradio Express. Hier geht es bald wieder weiter mit Technik und Gesellschaft und Kultur, wie ihr es gewohnt seid und wie das hier auch sein soll. Und ja, das war's. Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Tag und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.
Auf Wiedersehen!